l'année 2040 amis distance de la Terre
et du soleil voici un télescope d'un
genre entièrement nouveau composé de
milliers de miroirs dispersés dans
l'espace qui recombine leurs images dans
un satellite collecteur son but observer
la surface de planète lointaine
[Musique]
et voici la surprise l'image d'un monde
étranger à des centaines de milliards de
kilomètres de la Terre
regardez ces tâches bleues et vertes se
sont probablement des océans et des
continents et ces lignes lumineuses
peut-être des villes
[Musique]
monde de glace monde de feu planète
géante bientôt une nouvelle terre
comment apparaît la vie est-elle un
phénomène rare ou très fréquent dans
l'univers
[Musique]
des milliards de soleil des milliards de
planètes dans notre seule galaxie
combien abrite des civilisations
intelligentes
si la vie intelligente existe dans
l'univers pourrions-nous communiquer
avec elle et qu'aurions-nous à nous dire
[Musique]
ils existent pourquoi gardent-ils le
silence
et si nous étions seuls absolument seul
dans l'univers
[Musique]
bienvenue à tous chaque fois que par une
belle nuit sans nuages vous levez les
yeux vers les milliers d'étoiles qui
brillent dans le ciel vous vous posez
cette question presque inévitablement
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres mondes là-haut
plus ou moins semblables aux nôtres
d'autres planètes qui ressembleraient à
la terre en 1995 on a découvert la
première planète située hors de notre
système solaire une planète beaucoup
plus grosse que la Terre un monde géant
un monde de gaz qui ressemble à Jupiter
à partir de là tout est allé très vite
désormais on a découvert plus de 400
planètes la plupart sont des géants
gazeuses mais pas miel on a fini par
découvrir des petits mondes solides dont
la taille est comparable à celle de la
Terre et c'est là la vraie révolution
mais oui rappelez-vous le 4 avril 2007
une équipe d'astronomes français
portugais et suisse annonce que pour la
première fois on a trouvé une planète
presque semblable à la Terre autour
d'une étoile située à environ 20
années-lumière de
une découverte fantastique dans quelques
années à peine peut-être nous allons
enfin avoir la preuve que la vie a pu se
développer ailleurs que sur la terre pas
seulement une vie microscopique bloquée
au stade de la bactérie non des
organismes complexes évolués conscient
et peut-être même intelligent et qui
sait peut-être que certains d'entre eux
ont réussi à rabatir des civilisations
plus ou moins semblables à la nôtre
alors embarquons-nous vers ces
fantastique planète partout à la
recherche de ces nouveaux mondes grâce
auxquels nous allons enfin découvrir que
nous ne sommes peut-être pas seuls dans
l'univers
des planètes par centaines bientôt par
milliers nous le savons à présent
l'univers en regorge et peut-être sur
quelques-unes de ces planètes la vie et
pourquoi pas l'intelligence c'est le
nouveau rêve des astronautes
[Musique]
00 avec encore plein de zéro 24 0 en
tout c'est le nombre de planètes
semblables à la Terre un nombre énorme
de terre dans notre univers
que notre planète soit la seule planète
possédant une vie intelligente dans
l'univers ce serait ça le miracle
nous avons estimé qu'il y avait 31 513
civilisations intelligentes dans une
galaxie d'un milliard d'étoiles
personnellement je suis prêt à parier
pour dans un siècle que on va découvrir
la vie ailleurs dans l'univers
cette passionne des nouveaux mondes a
commencé depuis un demi-siècle par
l'exploration de notre système solaire
fascinant pour les astronomes les
résultats ont déçus ce qui attendait la
vie
[Musique]
mais cette exploration n'est pas
terminée loin de là et de nouveaux
espoirs se profil avec l'émission future
vers des planètes géantes Saturne et
Jupiter
2029 ce sera le grand retour sur Titan
le plus gros satellite de Saturne
rappelez-vous c'était le 14 janvier 2005
la petite sandwig gaz nous avait révélé
cette étonnant paysage de montagne et de
vallées comparable à un bord de mer au
sol sous le ciel orangé on pouvait voir
des galets de glace d'eau c'était un
autre monde si proche et pourtant si
loin d'une autre
24 ans après en 2030 une nouvelle
mission automatique libère dans le
crépuscule de titan deux nouveaux enjeux
une montgolfière de 600 kg et une petite
sauce
Athéna costennis correspondable de cette
collaboration Europe États-Unis nous
comptent ce fantastique voyage comme si
déjà elle y était
et dans ce crépuscule le ballon va se
déplacer à 10 km d'altitude et là vous
avez moins 200 degrés Celsius il fait
très très froid donc forcément les
caméras et tous les instruments qu'on a
à bord les caméras les analyseurs tout
ça vont prendre des images du sol mais
on va utiliser aussi un petit peu
quelques flashs pour pouvoir voir un
petit peu ce qui est tout en bas et tout
ce qui nous entoure quand on va passer à
travers l'atmosphère on va quelque part
aussi avaler les aérosols on va regarder
comment elle est faite cette surface de
quoi est faite cette chimie organique
qui va nous permettre de comprendre un
petit peu mieux le degré de complexité
de la chimie organique si elle a atteint
le degré qu'on a sur terre quand on a
besoin de fabriquer des macromolécules
et donner naissance à la vie et dans le
même temps donc ce ballon se déplace
dans un monde extrêmement froid et
extrêmement sombre
lâcher sur un des lacs d'hydrocarbures
de titan la petite sonde cherchera les
traces d'une chimie élémentaire qui
trahirait les présences de la vie
l'inverse se pose on a des instruments
qui sont en dessous qui sont en train de
d'aspirer le liquide qui se trouve dans
ce lac on est en train de le goûter et
avec tous les instruments qu'on a à bord
on va pouvoir faire des analyses
poussées qui vont nous dire d'une part
de quoi est faite cette atmosphère et
d'autre part cet intérieur est-ce qu'il
y a vraiment de l'eau liquide c'est ce
qui nous intéresse et pour avoir de
l'eau liquide à l'intérieur de tes temps
vous avez besoin d'ammoniac elle a cette
atterrisseur est en train de nous
montrer que oui il y a des traces
d'ammoniac dans dans ces liquides dans
ce lac et on s'est dit mais il y a un
océan à l'intérieur de titan un océan
d'eau qui peut être abrite la vie si
c'est pas aujourd'hui ça sera un jour
la vie on espère aussi la trouver sur un
seul un autre satellite de Saturne
regardez à l'horizon de gigantesque
geyser de glace d'eau jaillissent à la
surface alimenté par un océan intérieur
l'occasion est trop belle nous irons
aussi sur un seul homme notre mission
notre orbiteur s'approche et plonge à
l'intérieur de ces geysers à l'intérieur
de ses plumes et ramasse tout le
matériel que nous allons par la suite
analyser sur terre
[Musique]
compte tenu de la température très basse
la vie qu'on trouvera peut-être sur un
cela nous dit tant ne sera jamais qu'une
vie très élémentaire plutôt les
précurseurs de la vie que la vie
elle-même
pour trouver des formes de vie plus
complexes les espoirs se tournent à
présent vers les exoplanètes
c'est-à-dire des planètes qui orbitent
autour d'autres soleils que le mot
aujourd'hui un nouveau satellite porte
les promesses de la découverte de ces
mondes lointains et il s'appelle Corot
nous sommes à Toulouse dans l'enceinte
du Centre national d'études spatiales
voici l'équipe en charge de coraux
et depuis 3 ans le bilan du satellite
chasseur de planètes ne cesse de
s'enrichir la petite dernière c'est elle
c'est coraux de 9b c'est une planète qui
tourne lentement autour de son étoile
donc cette planète est gazeuse mais elle
est suffisamment loin de son étoile pour
avoir une température assez modérée
tempérée nous disons de l'ordre de la
température qui existe actuellement sur
la terre
malheureusement elle est gazeuse donc il
n'y a probablement pas de vie sur cette
planète
comment procède-t-on pour trouver
d'aussi petit objet à dossier grandes
distances il ne suffit pas seulement
d'accroître la puissance des télescopes
voici un petit montage qui illustre la
rotation d'une planète autour de son
étoile lorsque cette planète va passer
devant l'étoile il va y avoir une légère
baisse du signal de la lumière qui émise
par l'étoile la sensibilité de coraux
est-elle qu'il peut déceler de
minuscules baisse de la lumière émise
par les étoiles et donc avoir les signes
possibles qu'il y a des planètes qui
tournent autour de ces étoiles
il y a un deuxième principe qui est donc
mis en oeuvre l'étoile va elle-même être
légèrement attiré par la planète il va
aussi avoir un petit mouvement
d'oscillation et ce mouvement va être
détecté par des instruments au sol sur
des grands télescopes et cette seconde
méthode complémentaire est utilisée pour
valider l'existence de planètes autour
d'autres étoiles
fatalement au début on a commencé par
détecter des planètes géantes et
gazeuses donc impropre à la vie
mais avec les années les mailles du
filet se resserre les astronomes
découvrent aujourd'hui des planètes plus
petites et à surface rocheuse comme la
terre
pour atteindre le but final la
découverte d'une planète semblable à la
Terre il faudra attendre l'arrivée d'une
nouvelle génération de télescopes les
hyper télescopes
alors qu'est-ce qu'un hyper télescope
c'est un ensemble de petits télescopes
individuels réparties sur une surface
qui stimule en fait le comportement d'un
grand télescope unique et chacun de ces
petites télescopes individuels renvoient
la lumière vers un télescope qui
recombine la lumière de tous ces petits
télescopes
concrètement si vous voulez observer une
planète entière il vous faut 20 000 m²
de miroir
pour observer ses continents il vous
faut 80 mm² de miroir et pour découvrir
des traces possibles de vie il faut 500
mille mètres carrés de miroir et si
maintenant on cherche à voir par exemple
une image de la baie de Saint-Malo
depuis une étoile proche à ce moment-là
avoir des détails de l'ordre de 500
mètres il faudra considérer un
instrument dont les télescopes seront
répartis sur des bases de 300 000 km la
distance entre la Terre et la Lune et
pour une surface équivalente d'environ 5
millions de mètres carrés c'est à dire à
peu près 1000 fois la surface d'un
terrain de football
mardi 6 avril 2010 académie des sciences
de Paris
ce jour là l'astronome Suisse Michel
Mayor faisait une communication devant
ses pairs sur la recherche dans
l'univers de planètes semblables à la
Terre et bien on voit ces anneaux cette
structure qui nous renseigne sur
l'existence des systèmes planètes
en 1995 Michel Mayor fut le tout premier
astronome à jeter son filet sur la
première exoplanète à 40 années-lumière
de la Terre
la voici 51 Pégase une géante gazeuse
comme notre Jupiter mais la surprise
c'était qu'elle gravité tout près de son
étoile Michel Mayor en tremble encore
c'est complètement anormal une planète
de la masse de Jupiter qui tourne tout
près tout près de son étoile en 4 jours
les scénarios de formation des grandes
planètes ne permettait pas de comprendre
un tel objet et on a dû revoir la
théorie d'une manière fondamentale pour
expliquer comment cette planète qui est
obligatoirement à une grande distance et
bien elle a évolué ou se rapprochant de
l'étoile actuellement maintenant toute
la théorie de la formation des sixième
planète Terre doit inclure ce phénomène
une surprise dès la première trouvaille
et la suite sera à la hauteur plus de
400 planètes ont été découvertes en 15
ans toutes plus surprenante les unes que
les autres
l'immense majorité des planètes qui ont
été découvertes un jour sont nos proches
voisines c'est des planètes qui se
trouvent à quelques dizaines et
brutalement sont années-lumière cela des
distances considérables mais il y a une
expérience qui a été faite pour chercher
des planètes très très loin en gros on a
regardé pendant des mois en prenant des
photos successives très dose des régions
centrales de la galaxie c'est
l'expérience ogre
OGL
[Musique]
ons de cette petite planète qui a priori
n'a rien d'extraordinaire
ogre 0,5 390
nous glissons à la surface de son sol
gelé mais nous allons avoir une surprise
aussi plutôt glacée elle est très loin
de son étoile très froide comme ça mais
en plus elle est malheureusement
provient pas de vie sur une telle
planète mais par contre il doit y avoir
un ciel absolument superbe
[Musique]
pourquoi pas de la galaxie la densité
d'étoiles est beaucoup plus grande un
million de fois avoir plus plus grande
que dans notre voisinage donc imaginons
le ciel que l'on doit avoir vu depuis
tel planète une myriad des Toile 100
fois 1000 fois plus de mots sur le ciel
que ce qu'on a sur terre malheureusement
on ne pourra pas y aller
alors bien sûr ce que cherche les
astronomes
c'était mais où donc la trouver on
aimerait une petite planète un peu comme
la terre et qui soit justement à la
bonne distance pour qu'il fasse ni trop
chaud ni trop froid église 580d est la
première petite planète qui se trouve
dans cette situation c'est pas vraiment
encore du tout une planète comme la
terre elle fait 7 fois la masse la terre
comme un petit peu trop lourd comme ça
mais elle est dans la zone habitable de
son étoile
Michel Mayer émet aujourd'hui une
hypothèse très personnelle surglise 581d
[Musique]
une planète
océan
pour Michel Mayor ce serait à l'origine
une planète glacée qui aurait migré et
fondu tout près de son étoile et le
résultat c'est un immense
océan rien à voir avec le signe
extrêmement fun que l'on connaît sur
terre mais réellement un océan peut-être
de 100 km de profondeur
à présent voici un objet incroyable PSR
1257 + 12 qui a une fantastique histoire
cette petite planète qui orbite autour
d'un pulsar un cadavre d'étoiles qui
tourbillonne en émettant un jet très
intense de rayons X et ultraviolet
elle fut détectée par hasard en 1990 par
l'instronome polonais 5 ans avant la
découverte officielle de Michel Mayor
mais à cette époque les astronomes
n'étaient pas certains qui pouvaient
s'agir d'une véritable planète mais en
avait tort c'était la première
exoplanète jamais découverte
l'équipe de coraux elle vient de trouver
la plus petite planète connue à ce jour
Coro 7b à peine plus grosse que la Terre
elle tourne en moins de 24 heures autour
de son étoile c'est-à-dire que pour
cette B et si elle avait des habitants
l'année durait mois d'un jour ça
ressemble à l'histoire du Petit Prince
alors du coup puisqu'elle tourne en
moins d'un jour elle est très très
proche de son étoile elle est très
proche du feu donc il y fait très très
chaud mais comme elle regarde toujours
le même côté l'étoile comme la lune
regarde toujours le même côté de la
terre et bien d'un côté elle est très
chaude et de l'autre elle est
probablement très froide donc si on doit
passer d'un côté à l'autre il faut
passer de son maillot de bain à sa
combinaison de ski
15 ans l'univers a radicalement changé
de visage car il regorge de plein air
pour vous en convaincre nous sommes
allés sur le campus de l'université de
Berkeley où nous avons rencontré le plus
célèbre astronome américain
Geoffrey mars
avec Michel Mayor il fut l'un des
pionniers de la découverte des
exoplanètes
et devant nous à la cafétéria il s'est
livré un petit calcul alors suivez très
attentivement cela en vaut la peine
ce week nous pouvons évaluer le nombre
de planètes semblables à la Terre dans
l'univers entier c'est très simple à
calculer nous savons qu'il y a 200
milliards d'étoiles dans notre galaxie
et 15% environ de ces étoiles ont des
planètes
alors calculons
cela fait 30 milliards de planètes dans
notre galaxie
et maintenant voyons combien d'entre
elles ressemblent à la terre
probablement 50% de ces planètes
50% de 30 milliards cela donne 15
milliards de planètes semblables à notre
terre galaxie
si nous calculons maintenant combien
cela fait pour l'univers tout entier
cela donne quelque chose comme
100 milliards de galaxies multipliés par
15 milliards de terre
au total
00 et plein plein de zéro 24 0
un nombre phénoménal de planètes
habitables dans notre univers
on dépasse ici le domaine de
l'astronomie nous sommes en train de
vivre une immense révolution
philosophique qui change de fond en
comble la conscience que l'homme a de sa
place dans l'univers
[Musique]
à présent prenons le temps de contempler
notre terre
[Musique]
des jungles épaisses des chutes d'eau
des lacs des océans
[Musique]
ces paysages ne semblent pas fréquents
dans l'univers
jusqu'ici la plupart du monde lointains
détectés par les astronomes sont sans
doute des déserts gelés ou brûlants donc
stérile
[Musique]
mais la terre elle regorge de vie
dans la savane dans les forêts au fond
des gouffres océaniques dans des grandes
profondes et dans ces mégalopoles si on
n'est pas des millions d'êtres
intelligents ou supposés tels
comment expliquer cette exception
personnellement je vis très à l'aise
avec l'idée que la vie est un
sous-produit naturel de l'évolution de
l'Univers quand les conditions sont
réunies et bien la vie doit se
développer ça veut pas dire c'est
l'homme ça veut pas dire c'est une vie
identique à l'autre le plus probable
c'est aussi des des unicellulaires c'est
prouvant la front la plus généraleisée
qui peut exister personnellement je suis
prêt à parier pour dans un siècle que on
va découvrir la vie ailleurs dans
l'univers
sachez-le l'optimisme de Michel Mayor
n'est pas qu'une conviction il est
confirmé par des recherches très
concrètes menées dans les laboratoires
du monde entier
nous sommes ici dans des locaux liés à
la société française d'exobiologie
ce ne sont pas des amateurs de
science-fiction mais des biologistes des
chimistes des astrophysiciens qui
travaillent expérimentalement sur les
formes que la vie pourrait revêtir sur
d'autres planètes que la terre
dans ce laboratoire les exobiologistes
ont reconstitué l'atmosphère de Titan la
grosse lune de Saturne
le mélange dans l'éprouvette que voici
est composé d'azote de méthane et de
monoxyde de carbone
puis il est plongé dans de l'azote
liquide à moins 170 degrés la
température qui règne sur Titan
enfin on fait circuler entre deux
électrodes un courant électrique qui
stimule le rayonnement
ultraviolet du soleil
on laisse reposer quelques jours
et voyez le résultat
ses composés noirâtres qui combinent du
carbone et de l'hydrogène
ce sont des composés organiques les
briques à la base de la vie
en 1953 un jeune biologiste américain
c'est un des Miller avait réussi une
expérience semblable en reconstituant ce
qu'il croyait être l'atmosphère de la
Terre primitive
Ethan ammoniac hydrogène vapeur d'eau et
lui aussi avait obtenu des composés
organiques
pour le grand public ce résultat sonna
comme un coup de tonnerre le grand
public se rendait pas compte que c'était
aussi facile d'obtenir des composés
d'intérêts biologiques dans des
conditions expérimentales assez simples
finalement et cette facilité a été une
énorme surprise une énorme surprise
parmi les grands publics et puis une
énorme surprise parmi un certain
scientifiques qui ne pensaient pas qu'en
une durée aussi brève on pouvait
fabriquer des éléments constitutifs de
la vie
mais n'allons pas trop vite c'est une
chose d'avoir les briques encore faut-il
construire la maison
[Musique]
depuis plus d'un demi siècle nous savons
que les plans de l'édifice sont
consignés dans cette longue molécule
qu'on appelle l'ADN l'acide
désoxyribonucléique on ne la trouve pas
et là au fond des éprouvettes dans les
États-Unis bien évidemment on ne
fabrique pas de bactéries de
micro-organismes on ne fabrique pas non
plus d'acide nuclique ni même de
protéines
lorsque l'on fabrique ce sont les
briques de ces molécules géantes d'acide
aminés sont les éléments constitutifs
les briques des protéines on fabrique
aussi des petits morceaux des acides
nucléiques uniquement des petits
morceaux des toutes petites briques
maintenant pour passer de ces petits
morceaux à la macromolécule c'est un peu
pour passer justement de la brique ou de
quelques pierres jusqu'à la cathédrale
et ça ne se fait pas comme ça du jour au
lendemain
[Musique]
pour comprendre comment tout a commencé
il faut faire un grand voyage il y a
quatre milliards d'années dans cet enfer
la Terre primitive
[Musique]
des pluies d'astéroïdes des volcans
crachant leur laves un océan bouillant
une atmosphère irrespirable 100 000 fois
plus riche que la nôtre en dioxyde de
carbone
en 2008 dans un film d'animation au
style volontairement naïf des chercheurs
du CNRS se sont amusés à populariser ce
qu'on peut savoir aujourd'hui sur les
tous premiers temps de la vie
et ils ont choisi de nous compter les
aventures d'une petite molécule d'eau
puis colline
[Musique]
arrivé sur Terre à bord d'une comète
piccolina va assister à la naissance de
la vie dans les océans primitifs
tout d'abord elle voit passer des
molécules isolées et simples comme le
méthane ou le dioxyde de carbone
des molécules plus complexes comme les
acides aminés les fameuses briques de
stanleyminer
mais un jour picolina fait une rencontre
étonnante
un jour je suis tombée nezanée avec une
sorte d'énormes serpent moléculaire un
polymère
des dizaines de molécules s'étaient
accrochées à la queue leu leu que le
drôle d'idée
j'en croisais d'autres de plus en plus
qui semblait sortir d'une fissure au
fond de la main où j'étais tombée
j'ai voulu en avoir le cœur net je me
suis approchée et là quel spectacle
des molécules de la même famille
accrochées sur des cristaux d'argile se
rongeaient les unes à côté des autres
en fait ce petit voyage là qu'elle nous
raconte
ça montre la complexification de la
matière on parle de petite molécules
avec du carbone la plupart des atomes de
carbone dans leur structure et ces
molécules elles ont la propriété de se
complexifier de réagir les unes sur les
autres de devenir de plus en plus grosse
ça grossit ça grossit ça devient des
molécules géantes que les chimistes
appellent des macromolécules et parmi
ces macromolécules certaines vont avoir
la propriété de se répliquer de faire
des copies d'elles-mêmes et lorsque ces
premières molécules géantes capables de
se répliquer sont arrivés et bien c'est
la vie on peut dire que c'est
macromolécules qui font des copies
d'elles-mêmes et bien c'est le premier
système vivant
[Musique]
et c'est comme ça peut-être que la vie a
commencé sur d'autres planètes tournant
autour d'autres étoiles
mais la mèche quelques conditions
simples suffisent
si on claquant de ce qui s'est passé sur
terre qui reste la référence dans ce
domaine et bien il semble qu'il y ait
trois éléments indispensables qui sont
la matière carbonée l'eau liquide et des
sources d'énergie
et en fait quand on va aller chercher la
vie ailleurs dans le système solaire
pour commencer on va s'intéresser à des
environnements où ces trois conditions
ou ces trois ces trois ingrédients sont
présents
si ces trois conditions sont présentes
alors tout est possible sur notre
planète même on peut alors trouver la
vie dans les milieux les plus extrêmes
par exemple on découvre une vie dans les
fonds sous-marins à très forte pression
et là on a des systèmes vivants qu'on
appelle des barophiles parce que bah
refilent comme forte pression qui aime
la les fortes pressions dans des lacs où
les 16 sont très concentrées la Mer
Morte par exemple la concentration de
sel est à son maximum on a découvert et
on s'y attendait pas au départ on a
découvert aussi plein d'organismes c'est
ce qu'on appelle des des allophiles il y
a des organismes ceux-là sont sur route
les plus extraordinaires sont les
hyperthermophiles qui aiment les très
hautes températures et le record dans le
domaine pour l'instant c'est 121 degrés
arrêtons-nous là
nous connaissons maintenant les règles
du jeu de la vie
et nous voyons sur notre terre seul tous
les vantails des possibilités
or sur des mondes lointains c'est
éventail peut encore s'élargir jusqu'à
concurrencer les créations les plus
folles de la science-fiction
à présent allons plus loin
voici le Space need de Seattle dans
l'état de Washington le point de repère
le plus représentatif de la ville
à l'université de Washington nous
découvrons un étonnant laboratoire
le Virtual planet
ici les exobiologistes modélisent des
mondes virtuels qui aideront les
astronomes à mieux comprendre ce qu'il
découvre dans leur télescope
et récemment ils se sont posés une
question toute simple qu'elle pourrait
être la couleur de la végétation sur des
mondes orbitants autour de soleil
lointain verte et bien pas forcément
sur notre planète le feuillage est vert
car le verre et la couleur que les
plantes réfléchissent
sur une planète qui graviterait autour
d'une étoile très chaude qui diffuserait
une lumière très bleue c'est le bleu qui
serait réfléchi par les plantes à l'oeil
nu comme au télescope
[Musique]
ici sur l'écran nous avons du noir
le noir absorbe toutes les couleurs
sur une planète à côté d'une étoile
froide la végétation absorberait toute
la lumière disponible
elle ne réfléchirait rien elle a besoin
le noir dominerait l'ensemble du paysage
on aurait donc des planètes sombres avec
des jungles noirs
[Musique]
ces simulations peuvent être étendues à
des formes de vie adaptées à des
conditions très différentes des nôtres
par exemple une planète géante où la
gravité serait bien plus importante que
sur la terre
une planète à force gravité retiendrait
davantage son atmosphère au contraire
une planète comme la terre a perdu son
hydrogène ce qui lui a permis de former
la couche d'ozone sur une planète à
forte gravité nous n'aurions pas d'ozone
cela obligerait les plantes ou les
organismes à trouver le moyen de se
protéger du rayonnement
ultraviolet
une façon d'y parvenir c'est de vivre au
fond des océans ou alors pour s'adapter
à une force gravité la vie formerait des
communautés agglomérées comme ces
organismes fossiles qu'on appelle les
stromatolites
mais bien sûr ce qui nous intéresse
c'est la vie intelligente
sur quelle planète aurions-nous une
chance de la découvrir
nous avons une assez bonne idée de ce à
quoi ressemblerait une planète possédant
une vie intelligente il suffit de
regarder la terre et nous espérons
découvrir une terre dans la décennie qui
vient ce sera la plus importante
découverte scientifique des prochaines
années et ce que nous espérons trouver
ce sont des formes de vie
[Musique]
selon un autre exobiologiste Michel
Visot ce genre d'exercices trop vite ses
limites
il suffit d'imaginer l'expérience
inverse
imaginons des extraterrestres qui ont
observé la terre ils ont vu qu'il y
avait des terres émergées de la mer des
plantes de l'air ils vont imaginer des
formes de vie ou une forme de vie
adaptée à ces conditions dans leur
logique
quand ils vont arriver si par hasard ils
arrivent ils vont trouver un
foisonnement complet de la vie avec des
plantes des animaux des bactéries ils
vont trouver des éléphants des girafes
des mouches des oiseaux des formes de
vie extrêmement différentes qui
partagent en fait le même biotope la
même petite unité et donc on s'aperçoit
qu'il est quand même un peu vain de
vouloir supposer des formes la forme que
prendra la vie simplement à partir des
données physiques et chimiques que l'on
peut observer sur la planète considérée
donc si un jour on a la chance de
trouver une vie extraterrestre si on a
la chance de pouvoir la rencontrer
d'abord elle ne sera pas unique et dans
tous les cas on sera surpris
alors la vie oui sans doute mais
l'intelligence
en 1961 un radio astronome célèbre Frank
Drake a proposé une équation pour tenter
d'estimer le nombre potentiel de
civilisations extraterrestres dans notre
galaxie et voici ce que ça donne
comme ces frais pas c'est une équation
très simple combinant le nombre de
planètes ou la vie est apparue le nombre
de planètes où elle a évolué vers
l'intelligence le nombre de
civilisations capables de communiquer
pour les pessimistes le résultat se
ramène seulement à 1
une seule civilisation
la nôtre
[Musique]
mais pour les optimistes il y en aurait
plusieurs milliers
la tendance optimiste on la trouve
aujourd'hui dans la belle ville
d'Edimbourg en Écosse
dans la bibliothèque de l'Observatoire
royal nous avons rencontré un jeune
chercheur Duncan Ford qui a surpris son
monde en estimant le nombre probable de
civilisations intelligente dans notre
galaxie
pour réaliser ce calcul Duncan forgan a
pu avoir accès aux supercalculateur de
l'université qui a travaillé pendant une
dizaine de jours soit un peu plus de 200
heures sur trois scénarios possibles
dans le premier scénario nous sommes
partis de l'hypothèse que la vie
apparaît avec beaucoup de difficultés
sur une planète et qu'elle ne parvient
pas aisément à évoluer vers
l'intelligence
nos modèles informatiques donne un
résultat de 361 planètes dotées d'une
vie intelligente dans une galaxie d'un
milliard d'étoiles
et estime que la vie apparaît plus
facilement que dans le premier scénario
produites par ces formes de vie sont
régulés par un principe sociologique
élémentaire plus une civilisation met de
temps a évoluer vers un état avancé de
stabilité plus elle est exposée au
risque de l'autodestruction sous les
coups de ses propres technologies
dans ce scénario nous arrivons à un
total de 31 513 civilisations
intelligentes pour une galaxie d'un
milliard d'étoiles
le dernier scénario repose sur une
dissémination de la vie dans la galaxie
par les comètes et les astéroïdes
résultat
964 formes de vie intelligentes
évidemment la question est où sont-ils
le problème réside apparemment dans le
fait que si deux civilisations peuvent
exister dans l'espace elle n'existe pas
forcément au même moment dans le temps
or il faut que ces deux critères soient
réunis pour espérer un contact entre ces
deux civilisations
admettons pourtant que quelques-unes de
ces civilisations vivent à la même
époque que nous
à quoi pourrait-elle alors ressembler
en 1964 l'astronome russe Nicolaï
kardashev a proposé de les classer en
fonction de leur consommation d'énergie
d'abord il y a les civilisations de type
1 elle survivent en exploitant toute
l'énergie de leur planète
mais nous en sommes encore très loin il
nous faudra attendre sans doute
plusieurs siècles pour devenir une
véritable civilisation de Type 1
[Musique]
les civilisations de type 2 sont
beaucoup plus avancées mais beaucoup
plus rares elles exploitent toute
l'énergie de leur étoile
et voici comment on pourrait les
imaginer
un gigantesque ensemble Dano d'un
milliard de kilomètres de diamètre
édifié autour d'un soleil étranger mais
comparable aux autres
ce fantastique anneau permet à la super
civilisation de collecter toutes
l'énergie de son étoile environ 100 000
milliards de milliards de kilowatts pour
une étoile
identique à notre Soleil
à l'intérieur de ces structures vivent
des millions de peuples dans des
habitats façonnés à leur gré
bien sûr les civilisations de type 2 ont
des millions d'années d'avance sur la
nôtre elle maîtrise sans doute le voyage
interstellaire et des technologies dont
nous n'avons pas la moindre idée
enfin il y a les civilisations de type 3
elles exploitent toute l'énergie de leur
galaxie elles auraient un ou plusieurs
milliards d'années d'avance sur nous
oui mais encore une fois où sont-ils
normalement de telles civilisations
devraient émettre des signaux radio que
nous pourrions capter grâce à nos
radiotélescopes c'est le but du célèbre
projet City littéralement recherche
d'une intelligence extraterrestre le
problème c'est que pour l'instant le
ciel reste muet
[Musique]
nous voici à San Francisco
nous prenons immédiatement la direction
du sud vers la petite ville de Mountain
View qui abrite le quartier général de
l'association Setti
ici unlassablement on scrute le ciel en
quête d'un signal radio un signal
intelligent émis par une civilisation
extraterrestre
oui mais 50 ans ont passé et toujours
rien comment comprendre ce silence
ma mère me demande souvent si j'ai
vraiment choisi le bon métier
ma réponse oui évidemment car si on a
encore rien trouvé nos techniques
progresses elles doublent de rythme tous
les 18 mois environ et donc quoi qu'il
arrive cela représentera dans deux ans
une saisie de données plus importante
que celle collectées dans les 50
dernières années
c'est cela qui me pousse à poursuivre je
suis persuadé que les 20 ans qui
viennent nous apporteront beaucoup
monsieur chaustek j'ai une surprise pour
vous un message capté par le
radiotélescope de Nancy
pour une surprise ça n'était une ce
message avait été reçu quelques jours
auparavant par le radiotélescope de
Nancy en Sologne
principalement destiné à l'exploration
du ciel ce puissant radio télescope sert
aussi marginalement accepté
d'éventuelles signaux radio intelligents
et voici d'abord ce qui a attiré
l'attention des chercheurs
[Musique]
ça c'est le spectre des ondes radio
qu'on reçoit avec le radiotélescope de
nancet et là ce pic représente le signal
intelligent que l'on peut attendre d'une
civilisation extraterrestre il est
extrêmement fin là on le voit varier
disparaître c'est la présence et
l'absence de ce signal qui peut indiquer
un codage en l'occurrence le voici
revenu
on peut imaginer que c'est un signal
binaire une suite de 0 de 1 et qu'il
faut ensuite décoder
voici le message transcrit en binaire
une suite de 0 et de 1 mais qui obéit à
une logique cachée
si on compte on obtient 53 lignes et 11
colonnes et on obtient comme un petit
dessin
pour comprendre la suite il faut revenir
36 ans en arrière en 1974 avec le
puissant radio télescope d'avesybo
installé à Porto Rico les astronomes
avaient envoyé vers l'espace ce salut
aux étoiles contenant des informations
sur nos autres terriens les nombres de 1
à 10
les numéros atomiques de quelques atomes
et même un croquis de l'être humain et
sa taille et puis d'autres précisions du
même genre
et à présent on pourrait supposer que ce
message a été capté par des êtres
intelligents qui nous l'ont renvoyé un
peu modifié donc là on retrouve ce qu'on
a envoyé à recibeau c'est-à-dire que là
on a des chiffres 1 2 3 4 5 6 donc
peut-être que c'est envoyé par quelqu'un
qui compte en bassiste et par exemple
qui aurait 6 doigts là on a comme une
étoile peut-être et des planètes autour
donc là on compte 6 planètes et on
remarque que le la quatrième est un peu
décalé donc ils habitent certainement
sur la 4e planète donc voilà à quoi il
pourrait ressembler et là on a
certainement le radiotélescope qui leur
a permis soit de recevoir soit d'envoyer
ce message
à partir de là que faisons-nous comment
annoncer la nouvelle au monde
[Musique]
qui a réfléchit depuis longtemps à cette
question a mis au point un protocole
très précis
on pense généralement que la première
personne qu'il faudrait t'informer de la
réception d'un tel message devrait être
le président de la République française
et si c'était les Américains qui
captaient un tel message il devrait
informer leur président mais pour le
protocole Séti les messages
extraterrestres ne sont nullement
destinés à un pays particulier il soit
adressés à la terre en tant que telle et
sont la propriété de la terre tout
entière
en cas de réception d'un signal
l'article 1 du protocole SETI prévoit
des mesures très simples d'abord
vérifier que ce message est
véritablement d'origine extraterrestre
car il ne faut pas propager une erreur
la deuxième chose sera d'annoncée à tous
les astronomes du monde qu'un signal a
été reçu de tels coins du ciel et qu'il
faut braquer les télescopes sur cette
zone chacun en parlera aux autres tout
le monde sera mise au courant puis
entreront en jeu les médias l'opinion
publique les gouvernements etc
maintenant si nous voulons répondre à ce
message partant de ce constat très clair
les extraterrestres semblent très
intéressés par la forme humaine qui est
peut-être d'ailleurs leur propre forme
ce qui nous donnerait quelque chose en
commun on pourrait donc leur envoyer une
réponse de ce type nous partirons de la
même image de cette forme humaine
figurant dans le message reçu et nous
allons leur faire savoir que notre corps
possède différentes parties on va
centrer le message sur cette partie nous
avons des bras et ses bras peuvent
bouger puis nous reviendrons encore
complet où nous ferons un gros plan sur
par exemple nos mains
pour leur expliquer que nous avons cinq
doigts
nous pourrions aussi choisir de leur
donner des informations sur notre visage
ce à quoi il ressemble voici un visage
humain
nous zoomerons sur un œil pour leur
montrer que c'est pour nous un organe
très important qui n'est pas statique
qui s'ouvre qu'il se ferme etc
il s'agirait en définitif de leur faire
savoir que nous avons bien reçu leur
message et qu'en retour nous leur
adressons un message de bienvenue
[Musique]
et bien sûr hélas tout cela n'était
qu'une simulation pour l'instant encore
une fois nous n'avons rien reçu alors
question et si nous étions seuls
absolument seul dans l'univers
parmi toutes les planètes qui existent
dans notre galaxie probablement des
millions et des millions toutes ne sont
certainement pas intéressantes au regard
de la vie mais quelques-unes sont
certainement et cela dans notre seule
galaxie or il y a des centaines de
milliards d'autres galaxies chacune
composée d'au moins un milliard de
planètes alors vraiment penser que notre
planète serait la seule planète
possédant une vie intelligente dans
l'univers ce serait ça le miracle et
franchement en tant que chercheur j'ai
appris à ne pas croire aux miracles
et pourtant du côté des pessimistes qui
ne croient pas aux miracle on trouve le
biologiste Peter World auteur d'un livre
bombe
la terre rare
selon lui la vie a bon dans l'univers
mais l'intelligence est rare et
peut-être même unique
nous serions donc seuls
mais pas pour toujours
mais la question à mes yeux n'est pas
tant d'être seul et si nous étions les
premiers peut-être sommes-nous après
tout la première intelligence à
atteindre le stade du savoir-faire
technique mieux encore si nous étions la
graine qui permettra à l'humanité de se
propager sur d'autres planètes ou
d'autres galaxies oui cela serait une
vraie raison d'être optimiste en plus
cela serait tout simplement merveilleux
plus que jamais il faut se rappeler que
l'échelle de l'univers n'est pas la
nôtre
il nous faut donc rester patient attend
combien de temps nul ne le sait mais
pour certains d'ici 10 ans nous aurons
la réponse et ce jour-là pour l'humanité
tout va basculer
et finalement vous l'avez compris
l'univers est immense dans l'espace
comme dans le temps depuis sa naissance
il y a 13,7 milliards d'années et pour
que lointaine à laquelle toute la
réalité du monde primordiale proposait
sur quelques éléments seulement
étonnamment seul l'univers a donc
atteint une fabuleuse complexité depuis
le commencement des temps les puissants
constantes universelles les mystérieuses
lois physiques enfouis dans leur brume
mathématique étrange incontournable
allez se mettre au travail et régler la
matière pour la conduire coûte que coûte
vers la vie et si un beau jour on finit
par découvrir que la vie existe ailleurs
que sur Terre alors ce jour-là on saura
que dans l'univers rien n'est impossible
[Musique]
bienvenue à tous nous sommes heureux de
vous retrouver
Igor et moi pour un nouveau défi face à
l'avenir dernièrement voici la terre
elle tourne sereinement depuis des
milliards d'années dans le cosmos et
lorsque la nuit vous levez la tête vers
le ciel vous avez l'impression que tout
y est totalement calme pour toujours
immobile les étoiles et les
constellations hybrides en silence sans
que jamais rien ne change et pourtant
jusqu'à tout cela n'est peut-être qu'une
illusion il existe là-haut dans les
profondeurs du cosmos des choses ou des
phénomènes stupéfiants qui défient
l'imagination les trous noirs bien sûr
mais aussi les quasars les pulsars ou
encore les étranges magnéta c'est-à-dire
des étoiles effondrées dans le champ
magnétique et d'une puissance colossale
oui Igor mais il y a encore tout à
l'heure vous allez découvrir un
phénomène tellement effrayant qui laisse
les astronomes totalement démunis de
quoi s'agit-il de ce que l'on appelle
les explosions gamma imaginez en
quelques secondes à peine généralement
moins d'une minute l'explosion gamma
rayonne d'une énergie plus puissante que
celle des milliards d'étoiles de toute
une galaxie alors heureusement ces
objets sont loin très loin de nous mais
même à ces distances sommes-nous
réellement protégés de leur action
dévastatrice mais ce n'est pas tout la
Terre elle-même est régulièrement
affectée par des phénomènes parfois
dévastateurs les géologues ont découvert
que c'est cataclysmes ont provoqué dans
un lointain passé il y a des centaines
de millions d'années 5 extinctions
massives qui ont manqué de justesse
d'éliminer la totalité de la vie sur
notre planète alors quel point commun
entre ces phénomènes terrestres et
cosmiques les uns et les autres nous
rappellent que la terre est avant tout
une planète et comme toutes les planètes
elle a un champ magnétique elle doit
aussi évacuer sa chaleur son climat
dépend pour beaucoup de son étoile et
sous la main spellicule de son
atmosphère elle est exposée au terrible
feu du cosmos
dès l'aube de l'humanité les hommes ont
levé les yeux vers le ciel pour y lire
les signes précurseurs envoyés par les
dieux d'un possible anéantissement
mais ils étaient encore bien loin de se
douter que notre planète la Terre n'est
pas isolée dans son coin d'univers
quelle interagit avec l'ensemble du
cosmos
[Musique]
un exemple aujourd'hui chacun redoute un
réchauffement global provoqué par
l'activité humaine mais c'est oublier
que le climat de la Terre se décide en
dehors de la terre dans la mécanique
complexe qui régit la course des
planètes autour du soleil
[Musique]
résultat il est pratiquement certain que
dans l'avenir nous serons confrontés à
une nouvelle ère glaciaire
nous voici dans une bibliothèque glacée
à moins 25 degrés dans ces chambres
froides les chercheurs du laboratoire de
glaciologie de Grenoble conserve si
précieux archives prélevées en Arctique
ou en Antarctique expédition après
expédition
le principe est tout simple plus on
creuse profond plus on remonte loin dans
le passé l'outil du forage est muni d'un
couteau qui fort la glace tandis que les
copeaux sont évacués par une vie sans
fin
[Musique]
après des semaines de forage on atteint
des profondeurs de plus de 3000 mètres
remontant à plus de 250 000 ans dans le
passé
une fois découpé les carottes de glace
nous livrent les traces de la dernière
période glaciaire il y a 100 000 ans
qu'on appelle la glaciation de vos
alors une cassation ça ressemble à quoi
ça ressemble typiquement à ça
l'ensemble des continents de
l'hémisphère Nord couvert de gaz 2 km de
gaz sur le Canada les glaciers alpins
assez tendance jusqu'à Lyon on pouvait
aller à pied de l'Angleterre en France -
120 mètres de niveau des mers une
végétation tout à fait différente de
celle d'aujourd'hui pour le futur on
s'attend à ce que c'est le genre de
conditions ne soient pas rencontrés
avant 40 à 60 000 ans
[Musique]
l'origine d'une glaciation ne se trouve
pas sur la terre mais bien plus loin
dans le ciel
retenez bien ce nom mille outils
Milankovitch serbe et géophysicien c'est
lui qui le premier a compris les causes
astronomiques des grandes glaciations
[Musique]
et voici les deux responsables nos
lointaines voisines Saturne et Jupiter
[Musique]
ces deux planètes sont si grosses que
leur masse déforme périodiquement
l'orbite de la Terre et la rendre plus
élastique
le soleil devant alors plus lointain
l'énergie que nous recevons diminue
l'évolution de l'orbite de la Terre
autour du Soleil fait que la quantité
d'énergie reçue à la surface de la
planète changent au cours du temps si
l'on prend un de latitude la neige qui
tombe en hiver il faut qu'il y a
suffisamment d'énergie en été pour la
faire fondre si cette énergie n'est pas
suffisante la neige va subsister en été
on va commencer à former un glacier qui
va s'étendre or ce glacier est blanc
donc il réfléchit vers l'espace une
bonne partie de l'énergie reçue du
soleil c'est ce qui permet d'amplifier
le phénomène et du coup de rentrer dans
une cassation
pourtant les causes astronomiques ne
sont pas suffisantes pour démarrer une
glaciation que faut-il de plus et bien
dans ce laboratoire les chercheurs
recueillent dans la glace l'air qu'on
respirait sur la terre au cours de la
dernière période glaciaire
et qu'observe-t-on quand on mesure de la
glace formée il y a 100 000 ans on
observe moins de gaz carbonique dans les
petites bulles d'air que dans de la
glace qui s'est formée en période chaude
en période intergratiaire et ça c'est
une observation essentielle ça nous dit
que le gaz carbonique amplifié les
paramètres astronomiques pour en fait
rentrer dans des conditions de cassation
moins de rayonnements solaires moins de
gaz carbonique pour le retenir voilà les
deux conditions d'une glaciation
la prochaine nous dit-on devrait se
produire dans 60000 ans dans ce futur
très lointain l'humanité serait-elle
alors obligée d'abandonner la terre
rester prisonnière des glaces
ce n'est pas certain car l'avenir nous
réserve peut-être une énorme surprise
[Musique]
nous sommes au Commissariat à l'énergie
atomique de Saclay et voici Gilles
Rammstein Paléo climatologue depuis des
années avec son équipe il met au point
des modèles informatiques qui racontent
trois avenir possible
en fait tout dépend de nous de la
manière dont nous continuerons ou pas à
perturber le climat en rejetant du
casque carbonique dans l'atmosphère
[Musique]
pour commencer le premier scénario et
bien sûr utopique il suppose que
l'humanité dans sa grande sagesse arrête
immédiatement les dégâts dans ce cas le
cycle des glaciations se déroule
normalement
[Musique]
le second scénario plus réaliste imagine
une perturbation du climat importante
mais non merci
premier constat la calotte du Groenland
supporte mal cette situation et fond en
grande partie et puis on attend le temps
défile et on voit que rien ne se passe à
50 000 ans alors qu'on doit avoir une
poussée glacière absolument rien à 150
000 ans on devrait être pas oxygène
absolument rien et il faut attendre 220
000 ans pour que une nouvelle poussée
glaciaire
commence et quelle augmente jusqu'à
atteindre son paroxysme à peu près 100
000 ans après
enfin troisième scénario l'homme ne fait
aucun effort pour limiter des rejets de
gaz carbonique dans l'atmosphère
et cette fois dès le début de la
simulation le Groenland disparaît
[Musique]
les choses plus extraordinaires encore
dans cette simulation c'est que pas de
pousser de glacière à 50 000 ans pas
plus à 150000 rien à 220 000 et en fait
rien du tout sur les 300.000 ans de la
simulation
bien compris les mêmes raisons les mêmes
qui ont provoqué le réchauffement
climatique vous éviteront peut-être la
prochaine glaciation
alors on ne sait plus quoi penser
faut-il le déplorer faut-il s'en réjouir
après tout du moins a priori cela semble
être une bonne nouvelle
c'est sans doute à une très bonne
nouvelle pour notre 300000 ans mais pour
l'immédiat et pour en arriver là il
faudra perturber le système
environnemental tellement fort avec une
planète qui comporte 7 milliards
d'hommes que ce sera l'Enfer tout de
suite pour un hypothétique bonheur dans
300.000 ans je suis pas sûr que ce soit
le bon choix à faire
mais nous ne sommes pas encore là pour
l'heure ne perdons pas de vue que la
Terre est une planète avant d'être notre
maison sa logique et celle d'une planète
et ce n'est pas la nôtre en voici une
nouvelle preuve
imaginez comment faire la terre dans un
cocon
transparent le cocon laisserait passer
la lumière du soleil mais il serait
assez étanche pour être un bouclier
il protégerait la vie en déviant les
rayons cosmiques et les particules
mortelles qui frappent notre planète
lors des éruptions solaires
et bien ce bouclier invisible existe
c'est le champ magnétique terrestre sans
lui la vie sur notre planète subirait
des dommages irréversibles
[Musique]
un exemple le 13 mars 1989 une
phénoménale explosion solaire détraquait
les centrales électriques du Québec et
plongez le pays dans l'obscurité
[Musique]
imaginons les dégâts si le bouclier
magnétique n'existait pas
exception à la règle des splendides
Aurore polaires produites par les
particules du vent solaire qui
parviennent à franchir la barrière de
notre champ magnétique elle perturbe nos
ondes radio et peuvent être dangereuses
pour les spationautes
[Musique]
à présent nous voici au cœur d'une forêt
dans la région d'Orléans
ici loin des perturbations de la ville
des instruments très précis qu'on
appelle des magnétomètres surveillent en
continu le champ magnétique de la Terre
car nous le savons aujourd'hui notre
champ magnétique n'est pas stable et il
peut même s'inverser
voici deux fragments de base
l'un est âgé de 900 000 ans l'autre est
plus récent
approchons un magnétomètre le basalte
récent garde la trace de l'orientation
actuelle du champ magnétique le Nord au
nord le sud au sud mais pour le second
c'est l'inverse le Nord Est au sud et le
Sud Est au nord
et maintenant regardez cette carotte de
roche comme les carottes de glace elle
raconte à sa manière une partie de
l'histoire de la Terre
lorsqu'on regarde ses courbes on
s'aperçoit que une des caractéristiques
principales du champ magnétique c'est de
se renverser donc pendant ces périodes
d'inversion le pôle magnétique bascule
du nord au sud ou du sud de Nord suivant
la période à laquelle on se trouve par
exemple sur cette carotte qui fait 2
millions d'années on compte 4 inversions
qui se sont produites durant cet
intervalle de temps
et pour bien comprendre pourquoi le
champ magnétique terrestre s'inverse il
faut comprendre où il se forme
direction le centre de la Terre
imaginons que nous puissions percer la
surface terrestre et plonger dans les
entrailles de notre monde
d'abord nous traversons la croûte et
pèse d'une quarantaine de kilomètres
la température et la pression augmente
nous atteignons la couche la plus
épaisse le manteau
à lui seul il représente 80% du volume
de la Terre
mais bientôt le manteau se change en une
patte visqueuse et brûlante c'est le
menton inférieur épais de 2000 km
[Musique]
à 2900 km de profondeur nous passons
dans le noyau liquide un océan de fer en
fusion
le noyau liquide est bouillant car à
chaque instant il doit évacuer vers la
surface la chaleur terrible du centre de
la Terre
[Musique]
et enfin paradoxalement le centre
lui-même est solide c'est la graine une
boule de fer de 1200 km de rayon
or tout est là selon les jeux physiciens
ce sont les turbulences du noyau de fer
liquide qui génère le champ magnétique
terrestre comme une gigantesque dynamo
et nous allons le prouver avec cette
expérience réalisée au centre tonique de
cadavra
les chercheurs simulent des conditions
qui règnent dans les entrailles du globe
l'expérience commence
l'équivalent du noyau de fer liquide au
centre de la Terre
pour reproduire les mouvements
incessants qui agitent le noyau on
utilise deux turbines qui tournent en
sens inverse avec la puissance d'une
voiture de course
la montée en régime se pour
suit à présent le bruit devient infernal
et bientôt un champ magnétique apparaît
bon bah ça y est c'est bon
on est stabilisé là c'est parti ça y est
ça démarre vous voyez le champ qui froid
lentement il est bien sûr très
flucturant parce que les mouvements du
fluide sont remarquablement désordonnées
dans cette expérience
là il est parti il a une valeur moyenne
avec ses fluctuations mais quand même et
direction nord-sud alors les deux
directions sont possibles mais dans ce
cas là il a choisi de partir du côté
Nord-Sud
comme sur la terre aujourd'hui
l'agitation du sodium liquide a créé ce
champ magnétique par effet dynamo
mais si on poursuit l'expérience le
chant finit par s'inverser voilà là il
vient de passer dans la polarité Sud
Nord ou il va rester un temps aléatoire
remarqué au passage avant de repasser
dans la polarité Nord-Sud encore une
fois il passe par une valeur très faible
avant de recroître dans le sens inverse
alors pourquoi les inversions se
produisent-elles et bien on ne sait pas
le champ magnétique à deux États qui
sont tous les deux aussi et coups et
probables et le système peut choisir à
cause de ces fluctuations spontanées de
se trouver dans un état Nord-Sud ou dans
un état Sud Nord pour un temps
imprévisible et en attendant avant le
basculement un temps également
imprévisible
au passage vous avez bien noté comme
moment de la version le champ magnétique
passe par une valeur presque nulle
est-ce qu'il faut s'en inquiéter oui et
non alors vous voyez ce que j'ai
représenté ici c'est simplement la
composante principale bipolaire du champ
magnétique terrestre maintenant il
existe des composantes secondaires et
lors d'un renversement ces composantes
secondaires sont probablement préservés
voire augmenter de sorte que les gens
s'accordent à penser que la
magnétosphère a continué d'exister
pendant un renversement et à continuer à
protéger les gens
en somme notre protection magnétique ne
disparaît jamais
pendant ces fluctuations périodiques ont
certainement des conséquences
mais lesquelles
[Musique]
voici l'Observatoire magnétique de
Saint-Maur-des-Fossés déplacé en
province en 1901 à cause des
perturbations et des trou magnétiques
causées par l'arrivée du tramway
désormais dans ce laboratoire les
géophysiciens mesurent les variations à
court terme du champ magnétique sur des
vestiges archéologiques et ceux qui ont
trouvé et surprenants alors nous avons
trouvé des relations tout à fait
étonnantes entre les variations de
l'intensité champ magnétique terrestre
et certains événements dans l'histoire
des civilisations humaines alors cette
relation elle est pas direct il s'agit
d'une relation indirecte et ce lien
entre le champ magnétique terrestre et
l'histoire des civilisations serait le
climat par exemple ici vous voyez un
fragment qui porte la trace d'un de nos
événements géométiques il s'agit d'un
fragment d'un carreau de dallage qui
date de 14ème siècle et le 14e siècle
c'est le début du petit âge glaciaire
qui va ensuite durer jusqu'au milieu du
XIXe siècle donc là il s'agit d'un
événement géomagnétique et climatique
exceptionnel au cours des derniers
millénaires
alors voyez ici des briques qui portent
la trace d'un autre événement
germanétique dater cette fois-ci du 8ème
siècle après Jésus-Christ et le 8ème
siècle après Jésus-Christ est également
marqué par des phénomènes de sécheresse
en Amérique centrale et d'après certains
archéologues ces périodes de sécheresse
aurait provoqué la disparition de la
civilisation classique maya
[Musique]
le décor est la science identique ont
été établies anti pics d'intensité
magnétique et la disparition totale de
l'Empire acadien en Mésopotamie vers
2200 avant notre ère
ou encore celle de l'ancien Empire
égyptien à la même époque
[Musique]
dans un passé plus lointain il y a 40
000 ans les fluctuations du champ
magnétique terrestre nous permettent
peut-être de trouver une réponse à une
question énigmatique
il y a 40 000 ans l'intensité du champ
c'est considérablement affaibli et donc
le champ magnétique ne nous protégeait
plus comme il le fait d'habitude il est
frappant de constater qu'à cette même
période il y a 40 000 ans ces produits
la disparition de l'Homme de Néandertal
disparition qui n'est toujours pas
expliqué cette hypothèse du champ
magnétique donc reste plausible
puisqu'on peut supposer que lorsque le
champ magnétique est très faible la
couche d'ozone qui nous protège à
diminuer considérablement et donc on
peut imaginer que la pénétration
importante des rayonnements ultraviolets
aurait affecté considérablement l'homme
donnait un Vertal et provoquer sa
disparition
mais attention qu'on ne fasse pas dire
aux chercheurs ce qu'ils nous disent pas
les fluctuations du champ magnétique
terrestre ne font pas à elle seule
l'histoire des civilisations les hommes
sont sur le devant de la scène mais le
théâtre à son importance et le théâtre
répétons le c'est une planète
vu de l'espace la terre rayonne de
beauté telle un joyau le bleu profond
des océans la danse incessante des
nuages
magnifiques c'est certain mais il y a
tout de même quelque chose qui la rend
dangereuse ces entrailles sont en feu
des milliers de degrés et cette chaleur
infernale doit périodiquement s'évacuer
par tous les moyens y compris les pires
pour les malheureuses créatures qui
s'agitent à sa surface
depuis quelques dizaines d'années les
géologues découvrent le pouvoir
dévastateur d'un volcanisme géant qu'ils
appellent le volcanisme des points
chauds
ce sont des éruptions
qui mentent seulement depuis les régions
très chaudes du manteau terrestre
or sur la planète une région en porte
encore les énormes cicatrices les
trappes du décan à l'ouest de l'Inde et
au sud de Bombay
[Musique]
pour gagner le fameux site des trappes
il faut prendre l'autoroute qui va de
bomber à plume
[Musique]
puis on prend des routes de traverse
pour gagner le plateau de Marhaba le
cheval à 1500 mètres d'altitude
[Musique]
là notre guide nous demande de le suivre
sur un petit promontoire
[Musique]
et tout à coup voici les trappes à perte
de vue
ensuite doit le mot trap veut dire
escalier il décrit assez bien la réalité
ces montagnes ressemblent à des
escaliers mais des escaliers géants
tu es de la lave accumulée le produit
d'une série d'éruption gigantesque
datant de 60 à 70 millions d'années
et nous le savions puisque nous étions
venus pour cela mais quel choc quand on
est devant
2400 mètres de large empilés au-dessus
du sol sur une surface de 500000 km2
l'étendue de la France
décidément oui le volcanisme des points
chauds n'est pas un volcanisme ordinaire
[Musique]
alors pourquoi est-ce que le volcanisme
des points chauds et si violent il y a
deux choses il y a le volume des laves
et il y a la vitesse à laquelle elle
sorte le volume des laves il est
gigantesques parce que probablement ce
volcanisme provient des tréfonds du
manteau terrestre à presque 3000 km de
provenance sous nos pieds il se forme
une instabilité un peu comme dans ces
fameuses lavalents ses lampes du temps
de la civilisation et de la culture
hippie où on voyait une espèce de boule
de cire rouge monté chauffé par une
lampe quand la tête arrive à la surface
elle va craquer la surface elle va
entrer en éruption et nous allons avoir
ce volume énorme mais la question c'est
en combien de temps
plus nos travaux ont avancé plus nous
nous sommes aperçus que s'écouler de
lave sont arrivés dans des temps
extraordinairement bref en injectant des
quantités épouvantables de gaz
carbonique et surtout de gaz sulfureux
qui a créé d'épuises acides créer un
hiver puis une période de réchauffement
bref un environnement épouvantable qui a
conduit à l'extinction des espèces
[Musique]
car l'histoire de la vie sur notre
planète a été jalonnée de terribles
catastrophes et pour nous en convaincre
prenons maintenant une image suivons le
voyage du bateau de la vie sur 500
millions d'années
il y a 5 grosses catastrophes 5 périodes
où en un temps géologiquement très bref
une part importante de la vie sur Terre
disparaît la première de ces
catastrophes se tsunami qui va affecter
l'extinction des espèces on le rencontre
il y a 440 millions d'années à la fin de
leur domicile
[Musique]
la vie repart et on en ramasse un
deuxième dans la figure il y a 360
millions d'années au moment du Dévonien
[Musique]
et puis la vie repart elle atteint un
plateau là on a l'impression que le
notre bateau il est sur un grand fleuve
tranquille mais non ce fleuve n'est pas
tranquille on a une série de deux
extinctions qui sont les plus violentes
dans l'histoire de la vie deux
extinctions qui globalement vont effacer
95 % des espèces peut être 99 % de toute
la vie sur terre ça veut dire que la vie
est passée à 1% de l'extinction complète
il aurait fallu tout recommencer vous
imaginer des milliards d'années mais en
fait ce 1% ce sont nos ancêtres
d'ailleurs c'est les ancêtres de tout ce
qu'on voit sur la vie sur terre
aujourd'hui et bien ça redémarre ça
redémarre de plus belle et la diversité
dépasse ce qu'elle avait été au cours de
l'air primaire manque de chance très
rapidement à la fin du Trias il y a 200
millions d'années quatrième choc
[Musique]
mais ça repart récemment encore plus
haut et alors qu'on se développait
fantastiquement arrive la cinquième
extinction celle que tout le monde
connaît la fin des dinosaures il y a 65
millions d'années l'extinction de la fin
du Crétacé
[Musique]
selon Vincent Courtillot toutes ces
extinctions sauf celle de leur domicile
serait associé à des trappes repérées
en particulier la fameuse extinction des
dinosaures il y a 65 millions d'années
serait dû au volcanisme géant du décan
et à l'impact d'un énorme astéroïde dans
le golfe du Mexique je n'ai plus de
doute quant à moi que l'Impact a eu lieu
mais qui n'a fait qu'ajouter quelque
chose de pire à un phénomène qui avait
déjà commencé et qui est celui qui s'est
produit à toutes les autres extinctions
sans que cette fois là on puisse faire
appel à aucun astéroïde
et à chaque fois la vie est sortie
transformée bouleversé de ces immenses
extinctions rien ne sera plus jamais
comme avant
ce qui nous amène tout droit à la
question à quand le prochain tram
alors je peux d'abord commencer par vous
faire peur et pour vous faire peur je
dis quoi et bien nous avons calculé le
temps moyen entre deux trappes on a
toute une série nous n'avons parlé que
des plus importants mais il y en a plus
que ce que dont on a parlé il y en a une
douzaine environ depuis 500 millions
d'années bah en moyenne il y en a un
tous les 30 millions d'années ah et de
quand date le dernier gros le dernier
gros ce sont les trappes d'Éthiopie
c'est le plateau sur lequel est
construite la capitale d'adis-abeba ce
trap plat il a quel âge il a 30 millions
d'années le dernier grand trap c'est il
y a 30 millions d'années il y en a un
tous les 30 millions d'années le
prochain c'est demain c'est demain avec
une barre d'erreurs qui se compte en
millions d'années et quand un prochain
objet va monter des fonds du globe il
montera probablement à une vitesse de
quelques dizaines de centimètres par an
il déclenchera tout un tas de phénomènes
sismiques et volcaniques qu'on verra
sans doute un bon million d'années à
l'avance le problème c'est que l'espèce
humaine elle a en gros un million
d'années donc on a la durée de vie de
l'espèce humaine pour voir arriver le
prochain
[Musique]
donnons maintenant sur l'astéroïde qui
aurait contribué à la disparition des
dinosaures il y a 65 millions d'années
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les astronomes ont identifié
le responsable
un fragment de 10 km
issus de la famille baptistina un groupe
de bolides échappé de la ceinture des
astéroïdes et qui rôde dans les parages
de notre planète
question une telle catastrophe
pourrait-elle se reproduire demain ou
après-demain
réponse peut être
et le cinéma à grands spectacle ne s'est
pas privé d'user de l'argument
[Musique]
qui soit dans un rapport simple avec
l'orbite de la Terre c'est ainsi tourne
Jean-Yves Prado ingénieur au CNES
contribue aux travaux de plusieurs
organismes internationaux qui étudient
les géocroiseurs c'est-à-dire les
astéroïdes susceptibles de croiser
l'orbite de la Terre
en 74 d'entre eux sont répertoriés dont
1086 objets potentiellement dangereux
pour présenter un danger planétaire il
faut un astéroïde de diamètre supérieur
à 1 km il y en a un millier qui a été
découvert et aucun n'est sur une
trajectoire d'impact il en reste encore
quelques dizaines
répertoriés à identifier on peut espérer
que dans ces quelques dizaines il n'y en
ait pas non plus qu'il soit sur le
trajectoire d'impact
[Musique]
si une catastrophe planétaire semble
pour le moment exclue le risque d'un
impact avec des objets plus petits n’est
pas nuls en décembre 2004 un astéroïde
de 270 m de long baptisé Apophis avait
inquiété les spécialistes qui
redoutaient une collision avec la Terre
en 2029
Mélanie suivante l'alerte élevée de
nouvelles observations démontent
qu'elles office rattra la terre d'au
moins 32 000 km alors on respire mais on
a peut-être tort
nous sommes maintenant à Nice à
l'Observatoire de la Côte d'Azur et
voici Patrick Michel un des meilleurs
spécialistes européens des astéroïdes
il nous explique pourquoi en croyant que
office raterait la terre en 2029 on a
négligé un petit détail oui alors le
petit détail c'est celui-là ça s'appelle
un trou de serrure en fait j'ai dessiné
ici la terre avec la lune ici et donc
apophyse va passer à moins de 32000 km
la distance Terre-Lune est en 400000 km
et il y a un petit détail qu'on oublie
c'est que on a une petite zone
d'incertitude de 600 mètres dans
laquelle Apophis risque de passer et
s'il passe dedans et bien en 2036 il
tombe sur Terre en revanche s'il passe à
l'extérieur de cette zone et bien il va
rater la terre de plusieurs millions de
kilomètres et le problème c'est que
prédire s'il va passer dans cette petite
zone qui est vraiment très petite
nécessite de prendre en compte des tas
de perturbations qu'on n'est pas capable
de calculer pour l'instant d'où
l'incertitude
imaginons le pire quel serait les
conséquences d'un impact avec Apophis
elle serait terrible en pénétrant dans
l'atmosphère l'astéroïde se réchauffait
à 1600 degrés
l'impact dégagerait une énergie
équivalente à 34000 fois la puissance de
la bombe atomique d'Hiroshima
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la NASA estime à une sur
135000 la malchance d'un impact avec la
terre en 2036 et c'est plutôt rassurant
mais en cas de danger que pourrions-nous
faire
première solution pulvériser le bolide
bien sûr la méthode semble efficace mais
elle est risquée à cause des retombées
effectivement c'est risqué c'est
d'ailleurs pas du tout la solution à
envisager parce que quand on fait
exposer un objet on ne sait pas
exactement en combien de fragments on va
l'exploser on peut faire des très très
gros fragments qui vont tomber de toute
façon sur terre donc c'est pas une
solution ou alors peut-être quelques
milliers de tout petits fragments mais
qui vont aussi atteindre la terre et
s'éparpiller donc c'est pas la solution
et pour la plupart des astronomes dévier
le bolide semble le plus raisonnable en
2005 la NASA a testé la possibilité de
tirer un projectile sur une petite
comète baptisée temple one cette
technique pourrait dévier un astéroïde
de la taille d'un beau-fils
mais il y a encore une autre méthode
alors l'autre solution c'est ce qu'on
appelle le tracteur gravitationnel en
fait l'idée c'est d'utiliser un
satellite qu'on met à proximité de
l'astéroïde et la masse du satellite va
attirer l'astéroïde et on peut ainsi le
dévier de chacrage avec toi et donc
éviter la collision
et ici la palme de l'imagination revient
à ce procédé il consiste à envoyer
velastéroïde un parasol géant
alors la méthode à laquelle on pourrait
penser c'est de supprimer à des effets
naturels qui s'exercent sur l'astéroïde
la surface qui est en direction du
soleil est chauffé par le soleil et ce
phénomène là crée une petite force qui
s'ajoute à l'attraction des des planètes
sur l'astéroïde
donc si on supprime cette force on
modifie la trajectoire c'est un effet
qui est très faible mais si on cumule
sur plusieurs années on arrive à des
déviations qui peuvent atteindre
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres donc
par rapport à une trajectoire d'impact
ça peut changer complètement la donne
évitez de crier au loup mais y penser
toujours c'est pourquoi à l'initiative
de la société internationale
d'astronautique devrait être créé une
chaîne d'observatoire permanent des
astéroïdes
l'important c'est de les voir venir de
loin
[Musique]
mais contre toute attente il existe un
autre événement cosmique qui s'il
touchait la Terre pourrait avoir des
conséquences désastreuses il s'agit de
ce que les astronomes appellent les
sursaut gamma
d'abord nous verrions une grosse étoile
qui brillerait en plein jour
dans la seconde qui suit le ciel tout
entier deviendrait blanc brûlé par les
rayons gamma un rayonnement mortel à
haute énergie
et la suite serait dramatique
pour en donner la mesure nous nous
sommes rendus à Washington
à 50 km de la capitale voici le Godard
Space Flight Center un des nombreux
centres de recherche de la NASA
l'équipe que vous voyez travaille en
permanence sur les données transmises
par SWIFT un télescope spatial qui
traque dans l'univers c'est mystérieux
sur ce gamin
et justement en voici
[Musique]
il y a deux heures juste avant votre
arrivée Swift a détecté ce sursaut gamma
sur l'écran vous voyez l'image
on en détecte en moyenne deux par
semaine
on ignore encore sa distance on ne
connaît pas son énergie mais on va le
savoir dans quelques jours on fait ce
type de découverte environ 100 fois par
an
le ciel est donc bombardé en permanence
de sursaut gamin
certains sont de véritables monstres
que ce soit la voici un des sursaut
gamma les plus célèbres de l'histoire il
s'agit de oa au 3 19b il était si
lumineux qu'on pouvait le voir à l’œil
nu sans télescope il était situé
pourtant à 7 milliards d'années-lumière
c'est à dire à mi-chemin de la limite de
l'univers
mais qu'est-ce qu'un rayonnement gamma
et bien il est très facile de le
comprendre quand on regarde le spectre
des fréquences électromagnétiques
les rayons gamma ont des longueurs
d'ondes les plus petites du spectre des
fréquences électromagnétiques ce spectre
va de longues radio à l'infrarouge de la
lumière visible à l'ultraviolet et au
rayon X et enfin au rayon gamma une onde
radio a une longueur d'onde très longue
un rayon gamma a une longueur d'onde
très courte plus une onde et courte plus
elle a d’énergie et les rayons gamma ont
une énergie énorme qui les rend
dangereux il faut rappeler que les
bombes nucléaires produisent beaucoup de
rayons gamma
les sursaut gamma ont été découverts
accidentellement pendant la guerre
froide on croyait alors des explosions
atomiques soviétiques
on a compris qu'il venait de beaucoup
plus loin que la terre en fait des
confins de l'espace certains astronomes
imaginatifs ont alors cru à une sorte de
guerre stellaire en cours c'était bien
sûr les peuples de la célèbre saga de la
Guerre des étoiles
alors aujourd'hui nous savons que les
sursaut gamma sont émis par des
explosions d'étoiles certains sont
courts à peine quelques fractions de
seconde
un sursaut court est provoqué par la
collision de deux étoiles très massives
qu'on appelle des étoiles à neutrons en
tombant l'une sur l'autre ces deux
étoiles fusionnent en provoquant une
gigantesque explosion
quand les deux étoiles se percutent
elles déclenche la formation d'un trou
noir et les gaz accumulés au bord du
trou noir s'effondre en provoquant le
sursaut gamma
les sursauts longs qui durent plusieurs
secondes sont produites par des
explosions d'étoiles monstrueuses 40 à
100 fois plus massive que notre Soleil
ces étoiles super géantes évoluent sur
un tout autre mode que notre soleil
quand leur noyau explose il s'effondre
en formant un trou noir très massif
mais ensuite tout le gaz expulsé par
l'étoile est capturé par le trou noir
c'est une immense quantité de gaz qui
s'effondre à l'intérieur du trou noir la
conséquence est une fantastique
explosion qui produit ce sursaut gamma
long
mais rassurez-vous le plus souvent les
explosions au gamma se produisent trop
loin pour nous inquiéter et le
rayonnement se disperse dans l'univers
pourtant dans un loint tapassé le rayon
issu d'un sursaut gamma a peut-être
frappé notre planète avec des
conséquences majeures
reprenons un marche arrière notre bateau
de l'évolution
nous avions repéré 5 extinctions de
masse
les géologues parviennent à expliquer
les quatre dernières
mais la première elle restait
inexpliquée et si finalement il
s'agissait d'un sursaut gamme
pour résoudre une énigme nous nous
sommes rendus à Topica la capitale du
Kansas voici Brian Thomas
sastrophysicien professeur à la Washburn
université
et nous dit ce qui s'est passé il y a
450 millions d'années
mon hypothèse est un sursaut gamma s'est
produit il y a 450 millions d'années et
a touché notre atmosphère en provoquant
l'extinction des trilobites
ce sont des petits animaux marins de la
classe des arthropodes
nous faisons cette hypothèse car nous
avons retrouvé quelques-uns de cette
trilobite au fond dont le séance où ils
avaient le plus de chances de survivre
alors que les espèces qui vivaient près
de la surface ont été victimes de
l'extinction dans les fonds marins les
espèces qui ont survécu ont été protégés
du rayon gamin par la quantité d'eau qui
faisait écran
grâce au satellite Swift nous savons
aujourd'hui que les sursaut gamma nous
arrivent de partout dans l'univers mais
alors la catastrophe d'hier
pourrait-elle se reproduire demain et
comment évaluer la menace
du sursaut gamma et de la direction de
son rayon s'il est orienté ou non vers
nous
le rayon gamma deviendrait une menace
pour nous s'il se produisait à une
distance inférieure à 6000
années-lumière
traduction si le sursaut gamma se
produit à moins de 60 millions de
milliards de kilomètres de la Terre la
catastrophe est assurée et dans ce cas
quel serait le scénario
premier acte le flash
mais que se passe-t-il en Suisse
au lendemain d'un
assisterait à une modification chimique
de la haute atmosphère qui provoquerait
la disparition complète de la couche
d'ozone qui protège notre planète les
rayons ultraviolets du soleil
pénétreraient par cette brèche
provoquant de terribles dégâts sur les
organismes vivants
[Musique]
l'atmosphère se remplirait de dioxyde
d'azote un gaz brun rougeâtre analogue à
celui que produit la pollution
automobile
notre atmosphère deviendrait beaucoup
plus sombre car le sursaut gamma
provoquerait la formation d'une grande
quantité de dioxyde d'azote un gaz de
couleur brune qui absorbe toute la
lumière visible c'est ce qui arrive à
Los Angeles quand on ne peut plus voir
les montagnes qui sont autour de la
ville dans ce cas c'est le dioxyde
d'azote produit par la pollution qui
assombrit l'atmosphère
mais le pire est encore à venir
[Musique]
le rayonnement gamma provoquerait ce que
les militaires appellent une
IEM une impulsion électromagnétique qui
détruirait instantanément tous les
circuits électroniques
c'est donc l'ensemble de notre
civilisation fondée sur l'électronique
qui va suivre
voici William first jump auteur de
science-fiction et professeur d'histoire
militaire en Caroline du Nord dans un
roman récent basé sur des rapports
d'experts militaires il a imaginé les
conséquences d'une impulsion
électromagnétique due à l'explosion
d'une bombe nucléaire au-dessus des
États-Unis
situation serait identique empire s'il
s'agissait d'un sursaut gamma
le premier effet d'une impulsion
électromagnétique serait une coupure
générale d'électricité
immédiatement toutes les centrales
électriques
les avions en vol s'écrasent dans les
hôpitaux dans les maisons de retraite
les appareils de soins ne fonctionnent
plus
[Musique]
à la fin du premier jour les grandes
villes deviennent un vivables plus d'eau
plus de services médicaux les cardiaques
qui portent des pacemakers des scènes
les personnes âgées souffrent
terriblement car si l'événement a lieu
en hiver il n'y a plus de chauffage et
s'il se produit dans l'été il n'y a plus
d'air conditionnelles
en un jour à peine la vie dans les
villes devient impossible
au bout d'une semaine 20% des habitants
d'une ville comme Paris sont morts
il n'y a plus de nourriture ou
pourrait-on en trouver toutes les routes
sont envahies par des millions de
réfugiés en quête d'eau potable ou de
protection
et voici que surgit un nouveau problème
que fait-on des prisonniers
si on les garde en prison il meurt
faut-il les laisser sortir
chacun doit se poser cette question
c'est un monde pervers qui commence où
chacun devra se battre pour cela
[Musique]
certains noms après
seuls ont survécu les criminels
ou ceux qui ont su se défendre
des gangs des bandes se forment
chacun se bat pour un peu de nourriture
et ce n'est pas fini voici la troisième
phase de l'extinction
l'effet majeur d'un tel événement se
situerait au niveau de la stratosphère
où le dioxyde d'azote va perdurer de
nombreuses années avec pour conséquence
une diminution de la quantité de lumière
solaire cela provoquerait un
refroidissement global et probablement
une période de glaciation
encore une fois la probabilité d'une
telle catastrophe est très faible mais
pas totalement nul
il existe environ 7000 années-lumière de
la Terre donc finalement pas si loin une
énorme étoile en fin de vie il s'agit
d'État caréna un astre 150 fois plus
massif que notre Soleil
nous savons qui est Acarina est une
étoile susceptible d'exploser en
supernova et de produire un sursaut
gamma la question est de savoir si l'axe
de rotation de cette étoile est pointée
vers la terre ou non il y a des
incertitudes à cet égard si il est
effectivement pointé vers la terre le
sursaut pourrait contenu de sa distance
causé de sérieux dégâts à notre planète
mais si son axe n'est pas orienté vers
nous alors il se perdra dans l'espace et
nous nous contenterons d'observer le
spectacle inoffensif de la supernova
répétons le à l'heure actuelle nous ne
pourrions sans doute pas faire grand
chose contre un jet de rayon gamma
faut-il vraiment s'en inquiéter
heureusement on l'a vu le risque reste
faible
mais il y a plus à plusieurs reprises au
cours de sa longue histoire la vie sur
la Terre a croisé la route des feux du
ciel souvent elle a été meurtrie mais
jamais elle n'a disparu
[Musique]
car les feux du ciel ne sont pas
seulement destructeurs ils sont aussi
créateurs ainsi les explosions d'étoiles
massives s'y redoutables disperse aussi
dans l'espace les atomes lourds dont
sont faites les molécules qui sont à la
base de la ville
quant au rayon cosmique que nous envoie
ces explosions il provoque des mutations
dans l'ADN de nos cellules
et parfois pour le meilleur car c'est
peut-être l'une de ces mutations qui il
y a quelques millions d'années a permis
à un grand singe de se dresser sur ses
pattes puis d'évoluer pour devenir un
beau jour l'homo sapiens
et bien au terme de ce grand rendez-vous
avec les dangers venus de cosmos faisons
un dernier point certes les dangers
existent ils sont importants mais
rassurez-vous les solutions existent
elles aussi prenons l'exemple des
astéroïdes tous les 100 millions
d'années environ des astéroïdes de plus
de 10 km de diamètre reviennent frapper
la Terre notre globe a déjà été percuté
une cinquantaine de fois au moins par
ces géants venus de l'espace et il est
certain que dans un avenir plus ou moins
lointain un autre bloc de très grande
taille hélas comparable à celui qui est
tombé au temps des dinosaures viendra à
son tour frapper notre monde mais cette
contrairement aux dinosaure qui eux
n'ont rien vu venir et ont été balayés
par la catastrophe nous serons en mesure
de faire face à ce danger et ce qui est
vrai pour les astéroïdes géants
s'applique aussi à tous ces autres
dangers dont nous avons parlé sur terre
le volcanisme géant nous en avons eu un
exemple récent dans l'espace les
explosions gamma le défi est immense
mais nous serons le relevé à condition
de nous préparer dès aujourd'hui
d'inventer les formidables technologies
nécessaires en bref de faire confiance
en la science et bien oui Igor c'est
cela le sens de notre rendez-vous avec
vous aujourd'hui rendez-vous qui une
fois de plus nous rappelle que dans le
vaste univers rien vraiment rien n'est
pas possible
bienvenue à tous nous avons aujourd'hui
le plaisir de vous retrouver
Igor et moi pour explorer ensemble les
merveilles et les mystères de notre
monde pour enlever aussi certains des
défis les plus fascinants oui qu'est-ce
que avec tout de suite cette première
question vertigineuse est-ce que notre
cerveau se fantastique organe siège de
notre conscience de notre intelligence
est-ce que le cerveau n'aurait pas lui
aussi une face cachée autrement dit Igor
des facultés hors du commun mais que
nous ignorons ou que nous ne savons pas
utiliser par exemple la mémoire imaginez
imaginez que vous soyez capable en
lisant une page de tout retenir sans
oublier un seul mot imaginez aussi que
vous puissiez apprendre une langue
étrangère en quelques jours effectuer
tous vos calculs de tête ou jouer
parfaitement du piano sans avoir jamais
appris la musique un rêve et bien pas
tout à fait dans quelques instants
préparez-vous à d'étonnant surprise nous
avons été dans le monde entier en
Amérique en Inde
encore plus loin pour vous faire
découvrir des hommes pas comme les
autres des hommes phénomènes ils sont
capables d'exploiter vous allez voir ils
vont vous stupéfier et oui Qashqai
ensemble nous allons nous demander si
ces esprits hors du commun ne
préfigurent pas une sorte de nouvelle
étape dans l'évolution de l'humanité
que savons-nous du cerveau humain à peu
près ce qu'on peut connaître de la
partie émergée d'un iceberg et l'iceberg
servo est réellement immense 100
milliards de neurones et un demi
trillion de connexion possible entre ces
neurones autant que des toiles dans
toutes les galaxies de l'univers
[Musique]
dans l'histoire de l'exploration du
cerveau ce sont souvent des
comportements singuliers qui ont permis
de faire progresser les connaissances
c'est le cas aujourd'hui des personnes
atteintes du syndrome savant
[Musique]
après l'homme camera voici l'enfant
évaluateur prodige nous sommes en 2003
au Québec Julien a 9 ans et il souffre
d'un trouble envahissant du
développement dans son cas il s'agit
d'autisme et à la demande de ses parents
nous avons dissimulé son visage
pour tester ces extraordinaires
capacités d'évaluation l'équipe de
chercheurs canadiens va lui proposer
toute une série d'épreuves exercices
numéro 1 Julien doit estimer la
circonférence de ce cercle
[Musique]
que le temps est compté
le tuyau blanc ici jusque là-bas
et le résultat dépasse toutes les
prévisions les réponses de Julien sont
justes à 90%
pour le second exercice nous avons placé
la caméra derrière un miroir sans teint
afin d'éviter de déconcentrer Julien
comme ça cette fois il doit estimer le
poids de chaque vers
[Musique]
là encore les réponses sont très proches
de la réalité
dernière expérience encore plus
impressionnante précisons bien que rien
n'est truqué ni préparé
Julien voit cet ordinateur pour la
première fois
le but de l'exercice est de dire combien
de points apparaissent à l'écran julien
n'a que deux secondes pour lire l'écran
on ne sait pas exactement comment les
personnes avec troubles envahissant du
développement savent estimer avec une
telle précision Julien est capable
d'avoir une performance exceptionnelle
c'est à dire tellement supérieur à celle
qu'un sujet normal serait capable
d'avoir lorsqu'il compte le nombre de
points sur un ordinateur et pourtant il
s'entraîne pas à faire cette tâche là
tous les jours il a cette capacité là
probablement en relation avec son
trouble envahissant du développement
sans avoir eu à la pratique
que ces petits exploits ne trompent pas
l'autisme est une souffrance avant
d'être l'occasion pour quelques sujets
comme Julien de développer des facultés
exceptionnelles il n'empêche ses
facultés si surprenantes doivent trouver
une explication
[Musique]
notre enquête continue donc aux
États-Unis dans le Maryland et voici
Matt CV
Matt a été diagnostiquée autiste dès son
jeune âge et aujourd'hui il est
considéré comme un pianiste de génie
Dave Roubaix en personne assure nommé
maths le petit Mozart du jazz
il a joué avec des stars comme cheat
Korea Winton Marsalis ou chaque canne
auteur de 9 albums dont les sept
premiers composés entre 7 et 14 ans il
s'est produit sur de nombreuses scènes
dont le célèbre Blue Note de New York
question comment vous vient la musique
je ne sais pas vraiment
je ne sais pas si ça devient de la tête
du cœur ou des mains
ça se passe très simplement
vous entendez quelque chose sur quoi
vous construisez quelque chose
ce n'est pas très difficile écoutez
maintenant je pourrais aussi jouer ça
on peut créer de beaux accords à partir
de là
son talent mate le découvert une nuit
dans des circonstances peu ordinaires
avant cela il était considéré comme un
enfant difficile
question décrivez-vous à trois ou quatre
ans
[Musique]
Matt a choisi de nous répondre en
musique tandis que sa mère elle l'a fait
avec des mots
c'était un enfant difficile
il est sensible au son
à la lumière
tout le dérangeait
il était très tendu et il avait du mal à
supporter le monde extérieur
les médecins avaient diagnostiqué un
trouble cognitif en fait c'était une
forme d'autisme nous ne savions pas ce
que c'était nous ne connaissions
personne qui avait un enfant autiste
mais il y avait bien tous les symptômes
[Musique]
et une nuit
assis il arrive quelque chose d'étonnant
en quelques heures Matt découvre le
piano question que s'est-il passé cette
nuit là
[Musique]
suivez une thérapie pour travailler son
audition
[Musique]
on lui avait offert un jouet musical
qui lui permettait de reconnaître les
notes de base
[Musique]
un soir nous avons entendu de la musique
qui venait de sa chambre c'était sa
première composition
[Musique]
m'a donné l'idée de lui faire apprendre
le solfège
puis le piano
je lui ai donné des partitions pour
débutant et il a appris tout seul à
jouer et à lire la musique
je ne comprends pas comment il fait
c'est inexplicable
stupéfiant après avoir travaillé
Schubert à 7 ans mat rencontre le jazz
son talent d'improvisateur explose alors
et il se produit sur de nombreuses
scènes sort 7 disques en quelques années
son cas est si exceptionnel que le
docteur darold très fort le spécialiste
mondial du syndrome savant propose un
nouveau concept le prodige savant
les aptitudes d'un prodige savant sont
si remarquables qu'on pourrait les dire
géniales si elle n’était pas le produit
d'un trouble
ce sont des surdoués de très haut niveau
il y a peine une centaine de cas dans le
monde et Matt fait partie de ce petit
groupe d'élite
peut-être y a-t-il un lien entre
l'autisme de maths et son talent
[Musique]
il y a surtout une capacité de
concentration une prédisposition à se
focaliser totalement sur tout ce qu'il
fait qu'il a appliqué à la musique
[Musique]
aujourd'hui Matt poursuit ses études à
Boston et il passe les week-ends
[Musique]
et son autisme a quasiment disparu
il ressemble aux autres jeunes gens de
son âge en plus poli peut-être
et en plus gentil
Matt développe également quelques
talents propres au syndrome savant comme
des facultés de calcul exceptionnelles
ou encore l'aptitude à jouer les
calendriers vivants exemple le 8 février
1947 était un samedi la question est
posée à maths
le 8 février 1947
et 8 de 47
c'était un samedi
ces facultés se retrouvent dans sa
manière de jouer et de composer
il répète peu ne joue jamais de fin de
suite la même version et il commence ses
concert sans avoir fixé ces programmes à
l'avance
ces facultés sont si exceptionnelles que
darrold très fort en arrive à des
hypothèses qui laissent rêver
[Musique]
comme la plupart des prodiges savants
matent visiblement accès à une énorme
réserve mentale oui donc un réservoir
d'informations ou de talent ou de
facultés auxquels vous et moi nous
n'avons pas accès
disent qu'il n'est même pas conscient de
tout ce qu'il sait
[Musique]
le cerveau humain n'est pas statique il
a une histoire longue de 7 millions
d'années
[Musique]
de lucides la petite australopithèque à
l'homme moderne son volume a été
multiplié par deux
alors le phénomène du syndrome savant
pourrait-il nous montrer que cette
transformation va se poursuivre c'est
possible la réponse sera peut-être
livrée un jour par les techniques
modernes d'imagerie cérébrale
[Musique]
très peu d'expérience ont été faites sur
les cerveaux en activité des jeunes
prodiges du calcul mental
pourtant en 2002 une équipe de
neurologues français et belge ont
travaillé sur des facultés de ce jeune
calculateur allemand de 29 ans Rudy
Gargan
377 milliards 149 millions 515 625
[Musique]
Rudy n'est pas autiste mais il développe
un syndrome savant qui lui a donné
l'occasion de montrer ses
extraordinaires capacités de calcul à
l'occasion de spectacle à la télévision
pour tenter de comprendre la méthode de
felliger les chercheurs ont fait appel à
une technique d'imagerie cérébrale très
performante la tomographie par émission
de positron
grâce à des marqueurs radioactifs ont
visualise des régions cérébrales qui
s'activent lorsque Rudiger effectue
mentalement des calculs complexes
à présent réalisons la même expérience
avec ce jeune cobaye qui lui n'a pas la
bosse des mathématiques de ruddiger
alors où est la différence
l'analyse des résultats a montré que
ruddiger utilise pour ses calculs un
espace mémoire supplémentaire celui de
la mémoire à long terme
au contraire lorsque vous effectuez une
opération vous stockez les résultats
intermédiaires de vos calculs dans cette
petite mémoire de travail qu'on appelle
la mémoire à court terme
Rudy guerre bénéficie ainsi d'une poche
mentale plus grande aux capacités de
stockage majorées ce qui favorise ces
exploits
[Musique]
tomiquement le calculateur prodige a le
même cerveau que nous mais il s'en sert
différemment c'est toute la différence
mais comme vous allez le voir elle est
essentielle
[Musique]
tempête de neige sur la petite ville de
fond du lac dans le Wisconsin
ce médecin psychiatre qui a consacré 40
ans de sa vie au phénomène du syndrome
savant
[Musique]
en 1988 il
a été pour le film Rain Man inspiré par
le cœur réel du fameux kimpik le plus
célèbre de tous les syndromes savants
aujourd'hui disparu
j'ai rencontré Kim pick à l'occasion du
tournage du film Rain Man dans lequel
j'étais consultant je l'ai appelé le
mont Everest de la mémoire il avait
mémorisé 12000 livres mots pour mots et
en 15 ans il avait emmagasiné une
quantité incroyable d'informations sur
l'histoire les biographies la Bible tout
ça le plus frappant chez lui c'est qu'il
visait très vite un oeil sur chaque page
et il stockait toutes ces informations
sur le disque dur de son cerveau qui
n'affichait jamais attention mémoire
pleine
il a une mémoire stupéfiante
à ma connaissance
il n'y a jamais eu et je pense qu'il n'y
aura jamais personne avec une mémoire
comme celle de Kim pique
sa retraite Darol très fort reçoit
quotidiennement des dizaines de
courriers électroniques du monde entier
et maintenant de parents inquiets
je reçois des mails du monde entier de
Chine de l'Afrique du Sud du Brésil
surtout des parents qui demandent de
l'aide ou qui veulent développer le
talent de leur enfant
il y a aussi des chercheurs qui
souhaitent m'informer des cas sur
lesquels il travaille
[Musique]
le docteur très fort a examiné des
centaines de clichés radio de cerveaux
de personnes atteintes du syndrome
savant et selon lui tous auraient une
caractéristique commune Les personnes
atteintes de syndrome savants présentent
toute une lésion dans l'hémisphère
gauche de leur cerveau cette lésion peut
résulter d'une blessure ou d'un
traumatisme elle peut aussi être
d'origine génétique
nous sommes au cœur du problème il faut
se souvenir que notre cerveau est divisé
en deux hémisphères spécialisés
pour nous l'expliquer nous avons fait
appel à une célèbre neuro-anatomie le
docteur Gilles Bolt Taylor dans un hôtel
entre deux avions le docteur Taylor nous
a ouvert ses bagages
le cerveau humain est divisé en deux
hémisphères qui ne fonctionnent pas de
la même manière voici un vrai cerveau
humain
vous voyez clairement qu'il est divisé
en deux parties ici l'hémisphère gauche
et ici l'hémisphère droit chaque
hémisphère a une manière différente de
traiter l'information
traite tout ce qui concerne le moment
présent tout ce qui se passe ici et
maintenant il perçoit le monde comme un
ensemble où les choses ne sont pas
séparées où elle semble connecter
il voit le monde comme un tout et il le
voit en images
l'hémisphère gauche lui décompose ce
moment présent et il le découpe en
détail grâce au langage qui nous permet
de parler et de mettre des mots sur les
choses
et parmi ces mots il y a
je suis il y a le sentiment d'être un
moi de me distinguer comme un individu
et dès que je me pense comme un moi
comme un individu je me sépare je me
coupe du monde perçue comme un tout
comme une globalité
en résumé les deux hémisphères sont deux
machines bien distinctes qui traitent
les informations sur deux modes très
différents
[Musique]
à présent rappelez-vous le docteur
trefert avait remarqué que les cerveaux
de personnes atteintes du syndrome
savant présente toute une lésion à
l'hémisphère gauche et il nous livre
donc ce qui selon lui serait la clé du
problème
j'ai découvert que dans le cerveau des
personnes atteintes de syndrome savant
l'hémisphère droit compense la
déficience de l'hémisphère gauche et
cela en créant de nouvelles connexions
et en même temps il libère des capacités
dormantes
pour le docteur Treffert ce serait donc
en puisant dans ce réservoir des
aptitudes dormantes du cerveau droit que
les personnes atteintes du syndrome
savant réussissent ces prodiges qui nous
semblent largement hors de portée
[Musique]
et le plus passionnant c'est que ces
aptitudes existeraient en chacun de nous
pour le démontrer le docteur Treffert a
examiné les cas de personnes qui à la
suite d'un accident ont souffert des
mêmes lésions que les syndromes savants
et là surprise eux aussi ont réveillé
des facultés hors du commun
un des meilleurs exemples est celui
d'Alonzo Commons après une chute quand
il était enfant il a développé un talent
extraordinaire pour la sculpture c'est
aujourd'hui un artiste reconnu et
célèbre la lésion provoquée par son
accident lui a donné un accès qui
n'avait pas auparavant à cette réserve
d'aptitude et de facultés que nous avons
tous en nous sans pouvoir l'atteindre
la vraie question qui me préoccupe c'est
de savoir comment nous pourrions tous
accéder naturellement à cette réserve
sans en passer nécessairement par une
lésion cérébrale
parmi ces tentatives Darroll trefurt
nous invite à découvrir la méthode de
l'Américaine Betty Edwards
dessiner grâce au cerveau droit traduit
dans le monde entier il a rendu le goût
du dessin à ceux qui pensaient ne pas
savoir dessiner
le principe mettre hors circuit le temps
du dessin le cerveau gauche qui analyse
et laissez les élèves exprimer les
potentialités de leur cerveau droit
il ne s'agit pas seulement de développer
un talent pour le dessin mais de laisser
émerger une créativité qui ne
s'exprimait pas auparavant
si nous passions un peu plus de temps à
nous promener à nous balader dans notre
hémisphère droit si nous le laissions
s'exprimer un peu plus
si nous prenions le temps d'emprunter
des chemins de traverses plutôt que
toujours de prendre l'autoroute de
l'hémisphère gauche
nous devrions pouvoir nous aussi accéder
à cette réserve de créativité
[Musique]
bien sûr parler de cerveau gauche et de
cerveau droit est une simplification
notre cerveau n'est pas une carte
géographique comme on le croyait
naïvement au siècle dernier il se
caractérise par une étonnante plasticité
qui peut localiser à droite des
fonctions qui sont à gauche chez les
autres cependant dans la grande majorité
des cas les facultés d'analyse et de
raisonnement logique sont à gauche
tandis que les fonctions visuelles et
intuitives sont à droite
notre société est une société où
l'hémisphère gauche est dominant c'est
une société qui s'appuie avant tout sur
la logique et sur le langage
à tel point qu'on néglige les
potentialités de l'hémisphère droit
certains appellent cela la tyrannie de
l'hémisphère gauche tant celui-ci
occupe chez nous une position dominante
[Musique]
si quelqu'un se pose aujourd'hui en
apôtre du cerveau droit c'est bien le
docteur Gilles Bolt était là
ce qui lui est arrivé est incroyable un
matin de 1996 elle est victime d'un
accident vasculaire qui noix de sens son
hémisphère cérébral gauche
j'ai été victime d'un accident
vasculaire cérébral dans cette région de
mon cerveau gauche
quand un vaisseau a explosé la lésion
s'est amplifiée et l'hémorragie m'a
progressivement empêché de marcher
d'écrire de me souvenir du moindre
détail de ma vie
[Musique]
rappelez-vous le docteur Taylor est
neuro anatomiste avec une étonnante
lucidité elle raconte le voyage qui
depuis la lésion de son hémisphère
gauche la conduite progressivement à
découvrir les potentialités de son
hémisphère droit
[Musique]
en perdant l'usage de mon hémisphère
gauche j'ai perdu le souvenir de tous
les détails de ma vie c'est à dire les
informations relatives à mon travail à
mes relations tout ce qui est
constitutif de ma vie et de mes soucis
quotidiens tout d'un coup ce stress est
évanoui
il ne me restait plus que la conscience
et la beauté du moment présent et
c'était merveilleux
tout a changé alors
je suis passé dans un espace d'amour
l'ouverture de compassion de célébration
de la vie de gratitude pour l'être que
je suis
et quand les médecins m'ont guéri quand
ils m'ont redonné l'usage de mon
hémisphère gauche quand j'ai pu à
nouveau communiquer et interagir avec
les autres je les fais en gardant le
souvenir de ce que j'avais découvert
dans mon hémisphère droit
depuis plusieurs années le docteur Bolt
Taylor porte la bonne parole du cerveau
droit ce cerveau qu'elle dit programmé
pour l'amour et l'ouverture à l'autre
nous ne sommes plus dans la science mais
dans un prêche quasi religieux fondé sur
la révélation que lui a procuré son
accident cérébral
je fais l'hypothèse que la religion est
un mode d'accès à l'hémisphère droit de
notre cerveau
elle nous permet d'aller au-delà de
nous-mêmes de méditer sur les questions
essentielles de notre existence sur son
sens de nous arracher au tumulte de
notre hémisphère gauche à cette activité
fébrile pour explorer une zone où nous
sommes plus détendus plus authentiques
plus introspectif c'est ce que les gens
recherchent de plus en plus ils sont
tellement contraints par leur hémisphère
gauche qu'il recherche cet espace de
tranquillité et de paix et c'est ce que
nous apporte l'hémisphère droit
[Musique]
l'hémisphère droit nous connecte à la
dimension de la spiritualité il nous
ouvre à une vision globale qui abolit
les limites et quand les frontières
disparaissent on est offert à la
totalité de ce qui existe on sent la
présence de quelque chose qui est plus
grand que soi
on l'appelle Bouddha Dieu à la peu
importe car cette présence est là en
nous dans la conscience de notre
hémisphère droit
[Musique]
et ici faisons un pari
comme l'affirme le docteur Treffer la
civilisation
occidentale s'est construite de manière
dominante sur une représentation
rationnelle et analytique du monde
typiquement cerveau gauche il pourrait
en être différemment en Orient mais
est-ce bien vrai
nous voici en Inde à avidoir dans cette
ville au bord du Gange se déroule cette
année les cérémonies de la Coumba Mella
le plus grand rassemblement religieux du
monde 70 millions de pèlerins
l'événement le plus important le
pèlerinage est l'immersion dans le
fleuve qui nettoie les croyants de tous
leurs péchés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
certains de ces hommes sont considérés
comme des saints
leur but est d'atteindre un état
d'illumination
d'autres par des veilles ou de
libération
mais peu importe le mot cet état ne
ressemble à rien de connu
nous sommes au cœur d'une autre énigme
du cerveau les états de conscience
modifiée
[Musique]
l'étude de ces états de conscience
modifiée est difficile à mener sans un
minimum de pratique Christine le score
elle a choisi l'Aïkido psychologue à
l'université de Paris 11 elle a publié
une étude très fouillée sur la
conscience modifiée la conscience
modifiée est une autre façon d'être au
monde d'appréhender la réalité son corps
dans le temps et dans l'espace et nous
avons des États qui vont de l'excitation
extrême comme dans la transe de
possession ou le corps et l'esprit sont
totalement achetés
jusqu'à des états d'extase où on essaie
de faire disparaître en fait ces états
de conscience dans l'immobilité absolue
du corps
c'est un état étonnant dans lequel on a
une paix une tranquillité
extrême qui est un état extrêmement
difficile à obtenir
qu'on peut sentir par moment et qui
s'échappe et dont le but en fait c'est
de l'obtenir le plus longtemps possible
[Musique]
à présent nous allons tenter de
découvrir ce qui peut se passer dans
l'esprit d'un méditant ou d'une personne
en proie à l'extase mystique
ce jeune pratiquant de Harry doigt on a
une conscience très claire
[Musique]
la méditation consiste à oublier le
monde extérieur pour se tourner vers la
présence intérieure
nous perdons alors la conscience totale
de notre corps
ce véritable temple que nous utilisions
auparavant comme un outil
disparaît pour laisser place à une
vibration une énergie une présence faite
de paix d'harmonie d'amour de compassion
de conscience de la totalité c'est comme
si on plongeait dans le ciel l'infini
vous est ouvert vous n'êtes plus
différents des autres vous êtes un avec
le tout
[Musique]
et voici l'étonnante en rapprochant ces
deux images nous réalisons que nous
sommes tout près de la description que
Gilles Bolt Taylor nous faisait de son
état suite à son accident cérébral les
mêmes régions du cerveau seraient-elles
concernées
vous devez bloquer la partie gauche de
votre corps comme ceci
complètement
vous le fermez vous le verrouiller
en bloquant tout mouvement vers
l'extérieur
je vais trouver la paix
je me centre ainsi
je me porte vers mon cerveau droit où je
trouve justement la paix et l'harmonie
alors c'est en fermant la partie gauche
et en ouvrant la partie droite que le
flux d'énergie se produit
c'est donc clair la neurologue et le
jeune yogi décrivent à peu près le même
phénomène à ceci près que le yogi
cherche à atteindre un nouvel état de
conscience alors que Gilles Bolt était
là elle l'a éprouvé à la suite d'un
accident
[Musique]
mais ici une nouvelle question si ces
états de conscience modifiées peuvent
être décrits par ceux qui les vivent
est-ce que la science peut les observer
la réponse est dans ses images
en 1995 le docteur Andrew Newberg de
l'Université de Pennsylvanie a eu l'idée
le premier de scanner les cerveaux de
moine bouddhiste en méditation et de
religieuses chrétienne en priait
et ce qu'il a découvert dépasse et de
loin la seule expérience religieuse
on peut noter des changements
significatifs dans l'activité cérébrale
des personnes qui se livrent à une
pratique spirituelle comme la méditation
ou la prière un des principaux
changements se situe au niveau du lobe
frontal qui est fortement activé dans
ses pratiques où le sujet est très
concentré sur l'objet de sa quête
spirituelle
en revanche une autre zone est
désactivée dans la partie arrière du
lobe pariétal normalement cette zone
nous permet de nous orienter dans le
monde d'interagir avec lui
la désactivation de cette zone dans
l'état de méditation provoque cette
incroyable sensation d'unité de fusion
de connexion avec une réalité
ultime ou avec le but spirituel qu'on
cherche à atteindre
autrement dit l'expérience de la
méditation met en sommeil des fonctions
plutôt cerveau gauche celle qui concerne
la distinction le positionnement ou
l'orientation favorisant du même coup un
état plutôt cerveau droit d'unité et de
fusion avec l'univers
dans un tout autre domaine la pratique
de l'Aïkido permet à Christine le scandf
de montrer très concrètement comment la
recherche de certains états mentaux un
retentissement sur nos aptitudes
physiques
la façon dont on pense la façon dont on
oriente son attention en fait se reflète
dans notre posture dans nos actions et
on peut le voir très facilement quand on
fait des exercices de qui Aïkido donc
comme ceux que je vais je vais vous
montrer maintenant donc si j'ai peur si
deux personnes
dangereuses viennent m'attaquer et donc
essaie de me soulever par exemple et que
je me défends
et je suis très vulnérable il me soulève
comme il veulent maintenant je change
d'état d'esprit je me concentre
autrement je modifie ma conscience je
suis centrée sur le centre de mon corps
je me détends et je suis totalement
ancrée dans le sol on ne peut pas me
soulever donc ils essayent maintenant de
me soulever et en fait ça devient très
difficile pour eux et même dangereux
pour eux
donc un autre exemple j'ai 6 personnes
devant moi et je veux je veux les
pousser et j'y vais durement donc je
pousse durement et je peux pousser la
première mais les autres ne bougent pas
donc maintenant je vais changer mon état
d'esprit la façon dont je porte mon
attention ma conscience je me relâche
complètement et je pense à la dernière
personne à Adam qui est à la fin de
cette ligne
et j'y vais tout en relâchement mais en
penser jusqu'à la fin
jusqu'au dernier et je et c'est lui que
je pousse
jusqu'au bout jusqu'au bout
tranquillement
donc un autre exemple où ils viennent
maintenant essayer de me renverser et
moi je résiste physiquement contre eux
et effectivement il me renverse
donc maintenant je vais agir
différemment je me concentre
différemment de façon à ce que il se
pousse l'un l'autre je me relâche
j'étends
et jusqu'à ce que je dessine de m'en
débarrasser si l'Aïkido indique comment
un état mental peut agir sur le physique
on peut aussi montrer comment les états
mentaux renforcent certaines valeurs
morales en étudiant sous IRM l'activité
cérébrale de méditant en état de
compassion Antoine Lutz a découvert que
les circuits neuronaux des sujets des
mieux entraînés à la compassion c'était
transformé
nous avons constaté que chez les moines
qui pratiquent fréquemment la méditation
une région du cortex qu'on appelle
l'insula s'activer fortement à l'écoute
d'un son à forte composante émotionnelle
comme par exemple le cri d'une femme
effrayée
c'est une découverte importante dans la
mesure où cette zone joue un rôle
essentiel dans la vie émotionnelle
particulièrement dans l'empathie cette
aptitude a ressentir à partager les
émotions d'une autre personne
et rappelez-vous dans l'état de
méditation le sujet met en sommeil les
fonctions de séparation avec le monde au
profit des fonctions de liaison de
fusion d'empathie on découvre alors que
des vertus comme la compassion la
charité l'altruisme pourrait s'apprendre
et se cultiver comme on apprend à jouer
d'un instrument de musique
ce qu'on retient de cette découverte
c'est que l'expérience peut transformer
notre cerveau
nous le savions déjà c'est le concept de
neuroplasticité mais ce qui est nouveau
dans notre recherche c'est le fait que
la pratique fréquente de vertus comme la
compassion ou le souci des autres peut
aussi produire des changements dans
notre cerveau
[Musique]
les études nous invitent donc un
important changement de point de vue si
nos valeurs les plus fondamentales si
même le sentiment mystique ont une
traduction cérébrale on peut se prendre
à rêver avec le docteur Gilles Bolt
Taylor sur l'avenir du développement
humain
[Musique]
la personne qui saurait contrôlée les
deux hémisphères de son cerveau seraient
une personne libre elle aurait cette
vraie liberté personnelle qui lui
permettrait à chaque instant de choisir
qui elle est et comment elle veut se
situer dans le monde ce serait une
personne simple et menthe compatissante
curieuse qui vient vers vous prête à
célébrer la vie avec vous à créer avec
vous bien sûr elle utiliserait les
aptitudes de son hémisphère gauche sa
capacité par exemple à utiliser le
langage à classer le monde en catégorie
à organiser et à réaliser les choses
mais elle serait en même temps se servir
des aptitudes de son hémisphère droit
elle aurait l'esprit ouvert libre
conscient de la force vitale qui anime
l'univers elle serait désireuse de créer
quelque chose avec l'autre c'est
pourquoi je pense qu'il y aura alors
plus de coopération plus de célébration
plus de joie intérieurs et que
l'humanité sera plus saine
en Inde nous avons poussé notre voyage
tout au nord jusqu'à darhamsala
[Musique]
c'est dans la ville haute que loge la
plupart des réfugiés tibétains
malgré nos efforts malgré son accord de
principe nous n'avons malheureusement
pas réussi à rencontrer le dalaï-lama le
contexte politique de s'y prêtait pas
[Musique]
à la place nous avons interrogé un de
ses proches collaborateurs le lama gesh
il nous a confirmé le grand intérêt du
dalaï-lama pour la connaissance
scientifique de l'esprit
de kids cela fait près de 30 ans que Sa
Sainteté le Dalaï-Lama entretient un
dialogue approfondi avec les neurologues
du monde entier sur la nature de
l'esprit
ce dialogue qui a porté beaucoup à
chacune des parties a permis à la
science
occidentale de mieux saisir la richesse
de l'approche bouddhiste de cette
question
alors peut-être peut-être que
l'évolution se trouve au point de
rencontre de l'exploration moderne du
cerveau et des traditions venues
d'Orient
l'accent sur les possibilités qu'à la
conscience de ce développement et
d'atteindre un état délivré de toutes
les limites
cette évolution possible le lamagué la
résumé par ses mots l'humanité est
encore dans l'enfance de l'esprit un
constat que nous avons demandé à nos
invités de commenter à leur tour avec
leurs mots à eux
oui nous sommes toujours dans l'enfance
du cerveau effectivement et nous sommes
devant un formidable défi après avoir
trop longtemps
ignoré les potentialités de notre
hémisphère droit nous prenons conscience
aujourd'hui de l'importance qu'il y a à
nous y intéresser de plus près
je dirais que nous sommes encore jeune
mais pas que nous nous sommes dans
l'enfance
nous y étions quand nous n'avions pas
encore développé les fonctions de
l'hémisphère gauche et il fallait bien
que nous les développions afin de
parvenir à ce que nous cherchons
aujourd'hui à savoir un réel équilibre
entre les deux hémisphères
le temps est venu de prendre en compte
les caractéristiques de l'émisphère
droit afin de réussir cet équilibre qui
fera de nous des êtres complets c'est
ceux qui nous permettra je crois
d'envisager une réelle évolution
[Musique]
le plus important selon moi est de
parvenir à intégrer ce que nous apprend
la science notamment l'étude du cerveau
et ce que nous découvrons en étudiant
les pratiques spirituelles
comment trouver le moyen de comprendre
ce qui les unit certains nous appellent
des neurotéologiens parce que nous
cherchons à comprendre scientifiquement
la religion je pense en tout cas qu'il
est essentiel de mieux connaître le
fonctionnement de notre cerveau ce que
nous apprendrons nous aidera à mieux
comprendre qui nous sommes en tant
qu'être humain et à mieux nous situer
dans le monde qui nous entoure
[Musique]
et pour finir retour en France voici
NeuroSpin sur le plateau de Saclay une
création du Commissariat à l'énergie
atomique
à ce jour c'est le plus puissant centre
de neuro imagerie cérébrale du monde
disposant dément gigantesque
en explorant les régions les plus
secrètes de notre cerveau encore dans
l'ombre aujourd'hui la science de demain
pourra-t-elle éclairer sa face cachée
aidera-t-elle l'humanité à faire un
immense bon en avant et pourquoi pas car
s'il est vrai que nous sommes dans
l'enfance de l'esprit la science peut
sans doute nous aider à grandir
face au stupéfiants de perspective
offerte par NeuroSpin face à tout ce que
nous venons de voir tout ce que vous
avez découvert au cours de cette
fascinante exploration du cerveau humain
sans doute nous faut-il retenir trois
choses et tout d'abord qu'est-ce qu'un
on peut l'affirmer notre cerveau à bel
et bien une face cachée nous ne
connaissons qu'une toute petite partie
c'est 1000 milliards de neurones
possèdent des combinaisons à même des
secrets qui dépassent tout ce que nous
pouvons imaginer deuxième grand constat
un espoir grâce à ce qu'on appelle la
plasticité cérébrale c'est-à-dire la
prodigieuse souplesse de notre cerveau
il est possible à tous à chacun d'entre
vous de chercher des facultés nouvelles
et de les trouver d'améliorer par
exemple votre mémoire votre attention
vos dons pour le calcul mental et bien
d'autres choses encore reste le plus
important nous sommes sans doute à la
veille d'une révolution sans précédent
pour ce qui concerne le cerveau d'ici 10
ans 20 ans grâce entre autres aux
nouveaux ordinateurs et aux découvertes
des généticiens cette véritable
révolution cérébrale nous permettra non
seulement de bien mieux connaître notre
cerveau mais aussi de le faire évoluer
dans quelle direction c'est encore
difficile à dire mais à coup sûr
d'incroyable richesses nous attendent au
cœur de notre esprit et qui sait dans
l'avenir lointain le cerveau des hommes
d'aujourd'hui paraîtra peut-être aussi
étrange à nos descendants que peut nous
sembler celui d'une sauterelle ou d'une
libellule le défi est fantastique et il
nous appartient à tous de le relever
pour mieux connaître la face cachée de
votre propre cerveau pour en reculer les
limites et dites-vous bien que dans
l'univers rien n'est impossible
bienvenue à tous sur cette immense
tableau se trouve 40 000 gènes 3
milliards d'instructions c'est le génome
humain comme vous le savez c'est lui qui
commande la machine riz du vivant et
justement à ce propos sera-t-il possible
demain de vivre plus longtemps beaucoup
plus longtemps qu'aujourd'hui de
dépasser les 100 ans de vie peut-être
même 120 150 ans
les perspectives donnent le vertige oui
Grichka imaginez imaginez que vous
puissiez vivre 150 ans peut-être même
deux siècles mais attention non pas
comme un grand vieillard mais en pleine
possession de tous vos moyens avec le
visage et le corps d'un homme jeune et
en pleine santé alors est-ce possible et
bien jusqu'ici on avait de bonnes
raisons d'être plutôt sceptique mais
aujourd'hui tout change
médecins les biologistes sont de plus en
plus nombreux à penser que nous sommes à
la veille d'une révolution sans
précédent de sorte que si hier on était
vieux à 80 ans demain on sera encore
jeune à 120 ans mais pour en arriver là
que faudra-t-il faire et bien mettre la
main sur une mystérieuse horloge
biologique pour l'instant invisible qui
semble décider de rythme de notre
vieillissement et de notre durée de vie
mais oui et le premier pas c'est de
savoir où elle se trouve et comment elle
marche l'étape suivante consistera alors
à reprogrammer cette fameuse horloge à
la remontée pour que la grande aiguille
ne s'arrête plus à 90 ou 100 ans mais
bien plus loin 150 ans 200 300 ans
peut-être vous avez peut-être du mal à
le croire mais ces chiffres sont
aujourd'hui prononcés par des
scientifiques préparez-vous à de
prodigieux surprises ce qu'annonce la
science va bien plus loin que tout ce
que vous pouvez imaginer
dès l'aube des temps l'homme a poursuivi
ce rêve obsédant allongé la durée de sa
vie mais à travers l'histoire la
longévité semble liée à un secret une
formule magique qu'il suffirait de
posséder pour obtenir la récompense
suprême une très très longue vie c'est
le mythe biblique de la Fontaine de
Jouvence
parfois dans l'imaginaire les recettes
miracles en coexister avec de
mystérieuses vallées ou sans que l'on
sache trop pourquoi les habitants
semblent miraculeusement épargnés par le
temps
au-delà des légendes voici pourtant un
endroit bien réel c'est la Sardaigne 350
centenaires en vie et certifiés sur une
population de 1 million 650 000
habitants
au nord de l'île en cherchant un peu
vous trouverez cet olivier réputé âgé de
3000 ans
les habitants de l'île y voit le symbole
de leur bonne fortune mais quels sont
les véritables causes de la longévité
extraordinaire des arbres
pour le savoir nous avons suivi le
laboratoire mobile du professeur Luca de
Yann ce chercheur de l'université de
Sassari a organisé depuis des années une
veille médicale permanente sur les
patriarches de l'île et sur les
aspirants centenaires comme Antonio
Manua 96 ans venu nous rejoindre au
volant de sommeil
la consultation commence par une prise
de sang et se poursuit par un long
questionnaire mais si vous demandez à
Antonio le secret de sa longévité la
réponse est désarmante de banalité
pas de vis je ne fume pas et je ne bois
pas
même pas l'occasion et c'est tout
les vrais raisons de la longévité des
centenaires Sardes sont multiples
d'abord il semble bien que la longévité
s'hérite et se transmet le peuple sarde
est en rester isolé plusieurs siècles
les habitants se sont transmis de
génération en génération des gènes
protecteurs
voici Mariana Ferrer sans un an et
fièrement disposé derrière elle les
photos de ses parents et de ses
grands-parents tous ont atteint des âges
très avancés
dans les ascendants directs de Madame
Ferreri
centenaire qui vit à Turin
il est mort à l'âge de 94 ans
peut se transmettre à leur descendants
ou alors ne veut une nièce
le professeur de Yama nous a fait une
confidence en étudiant le sang des
centenaires sarde il vient de découvrir
des protéines qui joueraient un rôle
absolument capital dans la longévité
nous ne pouvons pas encore publier notre
découverte ce ne serait pas sérieux tant
que les procédures de confirmation sont
en cours
on aurait le lendemain des marchands qui
vendraient la protéine de la longévité
aux quatre coins de la planète
si la longévité s'hérite elle se
construit aussi par le mode de vie
une alimentation à base de produits
méditerranéens explique en partie la
longévité des Mathusalem sarde
Madalena SATA vient de fêter ses 100 ans
cette femme encore robuste s'est
alimentée de la même manière toute sa
vie comme ses parents et ses
grands-parents
chaque centenaire envoie un verre au
cours du repas
60 à 70% de polyphénols
ce sont des substances végétales qui ont
une action protectrice sur les cellules
je mange de tout ce que je fais moi et
ce qu'on achète au marché
je mange toutes sortes de plats
des ravioles des allées sans dorsales
des lasagnes que je prépare moi
des spaghettis aux moules aux fruits de
mer
tout ça
je mange des fruits de mer cru
les Sardes ont le stress en horreur
pour le mettre à la porte ils n'ont rien
trouvé de mieux que cette institution
qui a traversé les siècles la famille
ignore
réalisé encore ces jolies broderies
depuis ces deux mains l'eau lâchées mais
l'entourage protecteur lui est toujours
là
joue un rôle essentiel dans la longévité
des centenaires car elle exerce un effet
psychologique d'encouragement de
sécurité d'assistance
ce qui leur permet de réciter eux-mêmes
en atteignant cet âge de 100 ans
104 ans
nous avions je peux plus marcher comme
je veux
marchez plus mais vous vous portez très
bien
en tout cas la contribution de la
famille est très importante pour aider
la personne à devenir centenaire
donc il y a la famille bien sûr mais il
y a autre chose chez les centenaires
existent un trait psychologique
particulier bien observé par le docteur
Christophe de Geiger spécialiste reconnu
de la biologie de la longévité
les centenaires ont une autre
caractéristique sur laquelle on revient
que très rarement qui sont en fait leurs
composantes psychologique
ils sont loin d'être des gens toujours
très agréables tel qu'on a l'habitude de
les présenter vous savez on parle des
gens âgés comme étant des gens sages
sympathiques qui vont s'occuper de leurs
enfants de leurs petits-enfants de leur
arrière-petits enfants toujours prêts à
tout pour eux en réalité ce qui ressort
de toutes les études sur les centenaires
c'est leur aspect très rigide il ne
laisse rien au hasard
ils ne vont pas forcément vers les
autres
ils chassent le stress il le repousse
vers les autres mais eux leur vie est
parfaitement organisée ils vont se lever
à 7h30 toute leur vie ils vont déjeuner
à 7h58 toujours de la même façon allez
prendre leur courrier à 9h22 pas 9h24
9h22 et donc leur vie ne laisse rien au
hasard ce qui est parfois très difficile
pour leur entourage
je vais vous réciter la chanson de la
mort la chanson de la mort
ne viens-tu pas me prendre
tu vois bien que je suis toujours ici
bas chez moi sur notre terre
il y a une autre dimension à considérer
celle du moral
les Sardes en général sont convaincus
qu'ils vont vivre longtemps qui ne vont
jamais mourir il ne pense pas à la mort
et ils vont de l'avant on écartant les
obstacles devant eux
et c'est peut-être ainsi en oubliant la
mort qu'un Olivier sarde reste vivant
depuis 3000 ans mais tout de même la
longévité n'est pas une chose aussi
simple il y a ce qu'on est et ce qu'on
fait de ce qu'on est le patrimoine
génétique et le mode de vie leur chance
en Sardaigne c'est tout simplement qu'il
joue gagnant des deux côtés
revenons sur la petite Brooke Grimberg
la voici photographiée avec ses sœurs et
voici comment les années se sont
écoulées
[Musique]
quant à l'avenir il risque fort de
ressembler au passé
[Musique]
de sa vie nous nous sommes préparés à
voir Rook mourir
les médecins ont fait plusieurs tests et
les résultats indiquaient qu'elle ne
survivraient pas
depuis quelques années les médecins nous
disent qu'elles survivra et qu'elle
pourrait vivre très longtemps tant que
son environnement médical sera assuré
s'il reste identique elle pourrait même
vivre au-delà de 100 ans
donc jusqu'à présent on pensait qu'elle
allait bientôt disparaître mais
aujourd'hui on pense qu'elle va devenir
centenaire alors qu'est-il arrivé à Brou
de quel étrange accident a-t-elle été
victime
[Musique]
parmi tous les médecins qui ont examiné
Brooke le docteur Richard Walker occupe
une place à part
cette hormonologue respectée proche de
la famille Grimberg suit le cas de la
petite fille depuis plusieurs années
aujourd'hui retraitée à
Saint-Pétersbourg en Floride du Sud il
profite de son temps libre pour
rassembler toutes ces analyses en une
théorie générale des causes du
vieillissement
j'ai vu Brooke pour la première fois à
la télé dans l'émission deadlines et
j'ai compris immédiatement que le cas de
cet enfant pouvait ouvrir de nouvelles
perspectives sur le processus du
vieillissement
j'ai contacté ses parents Monsieur et
Madame Grimberg et je leur ai dit mon
intérêt pour le cas de leur fille
je ne leur proposais pas un traitement
je pensais que son cas permettrait à la
science de progresser de comprendre
mieux pourquoi nous vieillissons
pourquoi nous sommes mortels
le docteur Walker à la certitude qu'un
mécanisme fondamental c'est enrayé
bloqué chez Brook un mécanisme qu'il
s'agit maintenant d'élucider
la condition de Brooke résulte
probablement d'une mutation génétique
qui a provoqué le ralentissement de son
développement et sa désorganisation
à d'autres mutations génétiques comme la
progéria ou le syndrome de Werner où
nous observons une accélération du
vieillissement dans le cas de bouc le
facteur génétique a provoqué un
ralentissement de ce processus
les dérèglements génétiques ont le
mérite de nous rappeler la règle chaque
espèce vivante est génétiquement
programmée pour une durée de vie bien
précise et cela est vrai du plus infime
moucheron jusqu'à l'éléphant et bien sûr
alors
commençons par ces fourmis selon les
espèces leur durée de vie sèche l'homme
de quelques semaines à un an
mais certaines vivent jusqu'à 30 ans
et on peut continuer comme un jeu ainsi
quelle est la durée de vie maximale d'un
perroquet 40 ans
75 ans ou bien 120 ans réfléchissez
et bien la réponse 120 à présent un
éléphant
70 ans 80 ans ou encore 110 ans
réponse 70 ans
enfin une mouette non 5 ans ou encore 15
ans
réponse 15
[Musique]
d'autres espèces comme les tortues ont
une biologie qui leur permet de vivre
plus longtemps
écoutez Marie-Claude Bomsel professeur
au Muséum d'histoire naturelle
si le terme c'est à dire qu'elles ont
une température qui va varier en
fonction du milieu extérieur elles
utilisent l'énergie solaire c'est en
fait des piles solaires elles ont
inventé l'économie durable bien avant
nous elles ont un autre avantage elles
sont herbivores donc faciliter de
digestion expression assez lente mais
bonnes elles ont par ailleurs une grande
taille donc accumulation d'énergie
maximale plus un coup de reproduction
très bas parce qu'elle pompe des œufs et
elle s'en vont ça signifie une vie très
longue car qui veut ménager sa monture
et bien vive lentement c'est leur propos
elles peuvent vivre jusqu'à 150 ans
c'est énorme un serpent lui le vivra que
40 50 ans c'est le maximum parce qu'il
mange de la viande et que ça c'est
beaucoup plus difficile à digérer et que
ce raccourcit le temps
au contraire chez les animaux à sang
chaud la phase de la vieillesse est bien
plus marquée ici nous avons affaire à
des mammifères des animaux homéothermes
ils doivent maintenir une température à
38 degrés pour avoir une température 38
degrés il faut avoir du combustible la
combustible c'est la nourriture on le
voit ils sont bien ronds nénette 40 ans
tout beau saison nénette elle par
exemple en tant que femelle va avoir
évidemment un coup de reproduction très
lourd il faut fabriquer un petit à
coucher le nourrir c'est très très long
et donc les machines susent beaucoup
plus vite donc ces animaux-là vivront 40
45 ans ça n'est pas très long c'est
comme l'homme sauf mon tout beau à mon
avis mon tout beau un mot tout beau nous
on vivra un amour éternel tu vas bien
vivre encore avec moi une centaine
d'années
[Musique]
un des cas les plus étonnants reste
celui des saumons du Pacifique qui
meurent après un unique épisode de ponte
leur instinct les pousse à remonter les
rivières pour venir se reproduire à
l'endroit précis où ils sont nés
un voyage éprouvant que les saumons
réalise sans prendre la moindre
nourriture
et enfin parvenu à destination la
femelle pond ses œufs et le mal les
fertilisent à partir de là les saumons
sont condamnés
en quelques jours de brutal décharge
hormonales les transforment en individu
chétifs et vieillissant la vie leur
signale qu'il est temps pour eux de
disparaître et c'est ce qu'ils font en
coeur et par milliers
bref dès la naissance de l'Alvin son
avenir est programmé dans deux ou trois
ans il viendra mourir ici à l'endroit
même où il est né juste après son unique
reproduction
[Musique]
mais alors pourquoi pourquoi la nature
a-t-elle attribué aux êtres vivants des
longévités si différentes par fantaisie
par caprice par hasard ou bien est-ce
qu'il y aurait derrière cette diversité
une raison cachée si on cherche une
logique à la longévité je vais vous le
dire tout de suite il n'y en a aucune
tout simplement parce que pour la nature
il faut vivre survivre et surtout se
reproduire pour que l'espèce soit
pérenne l'individu ne compte pas en
lui-même en d'autres termes la nature
est économe elle accorde juste le temps
nécessaire aux êtres vivants pour se
reproduire
mais l'homme lui vient troubler le jeu
écoutez ce qu'en dit le docteur de
Geiger il y a guère que l'homme qui
cherche à échapper à son destin l'homme
se reproduit
il fait des enfants donc normalement à
partir de là il y a même pas besoin de
parler de retraite normalement il
devrait disparaître puisque ça devient
une bouchée utile si on se place d'un
point de vue de l'espèce bien évidemment
et non et bien lui l'homme il veut
rester il veut en profiter il veut
profiter de cette retraite durement
acquise et il veut changer en réalité
son destin et c'est là où il va remettre
en question complètement l'évolution de
l'espèce et nous risquons d'avoir des
surprises par rapport à ça
[Musique]
donc l'homme veut changer son destin en
essayant de comprendre comment
fonctionne la machine biologique que
nous a légué la nature
[Musique]
d'abord c'est l'émerveillement
comme un bel avion de ligne la machine
du vivant se révèle parfaitement
organisé parfaitement auto-réparé par un
service de maintenance invisible mais
très efficace
sauf que peu à peu ce service se relâche
et provoque le vieillissement pourquoi
après quelques dizaines d'années la
machine se détraque-t-elle
regardez la petite boucle est-il bien
juste de dire que c'est un enfant n'a
pas vieilli
absolument pas elle vieillit même si ce
vieillissement est très lent si vous
observez comment elle se développe vous
verrez qu'il vieillit mais il y a des
rythmes différents
son cerveau par exemple
s'avère être le cerveau d'un enfant qui
aurait moins d'un an
d'un autre côté sa dentition et celle
d'un enfant de 6 ou 7 ans
de même si vous observez son squelette
vous constaterez que ces eaux sont ceux
d'un enfant de 10 ans
en revanche d'autres cellules de son
organisme sont synchrones avec son âge
réel soit 17 ans voir un peu plus
donc Brook vieillit bien sûr comme nous
tous mais d'une manière anarchique
désorganisée cette observation a permis
au docteur Walker de proposer une
nouvelle manière de comprendre le
processus du vieillissement écoutez-le
attentivement et tout va devenir
lumineux
notre organisme est d'abord le produit
d'une reproduction sexuelle dans la
mesure où nous commençons notre vie à
partir d'une cellule simple à neuf
fécondé mais ensuite notre organisme
subit une transformation dynamique qui
le mène jusqu'à l'âge adulte ce
processus ne se fait pas au hasard il
est entièrement pris en charge par un
certain nombre de gènes qu'on appelle
des gènes de régulation qui nous
conduisent de la simple cellule jusqu'à
l'âge adulte
[Musique]
Richard Walker nous a proposé de
comparer le développement de chaque
individu quel qu'il soit à un orchestre
et d'abord voyons comment se
répartissent les rôles
[Musique]
et si nous comparons l'organisme à un
orchestre nous pourrions dire que
l'organisme est représenté par les
musiciens tandis que les gènes de
régulation sont représentés par le chef
d'orchestre qui dirige les musiciens et
qui les aident à développer le thème
jusqu'à la maturité
progressivement sous la direction
précise du chef les musiciens joignent
leur talents pour développer le
magnifique thème écrit dans la partition
et c'est ainsi qu'un être humain grandit
et se développe depuis l'enfance jusqu'à
la maturité sexuelle
notre organisme atteint un état de
perfection physique vers l'âge de 18 20
ans jusque là le développement de
l'organisme est contrôlé comme nous
l'avons vu par des gènes de régulation
mais au-delà de cet âge il n'y a plus
d'informations disponibles
et nous voici au moment précis où le
chef d'orchestre tourne une page de sa
partition et soudain découvre que la
suivante est vierge la situation est
identique pour chaque interprète alors
que s'est-il passé
rappelez-vous la vie dans sa logique
aveugle privilégie la reproduction une
fois que l'organisme s'est reproduit il
peut disparaître et c'est si vrai que la
vie a négligé d'écrire la suite de la
partition c'est-à-dire l'information
génétique permettant un organisme de
durée au-delà de l'âge de la
reproduction
à partir de là le chef d'orchestre
continue à diriger orchestre a agité sa
baguette bien qu'il n'y ait plus de
musique à jouer si bien que chaque
musicien se met à jouer pour soi
résultat cette absence de coordination
conduit à une détérioration complète de
la musique c'est exactement ce qui se
passe dans notre corps
si l'hypothèse centrale du docteur
Walker à partir de notre maturité
sexuelle vers 18 ou 20 ans notre
organisme comme cet orchestre devenu fou
ne dispose plus de la séquence
d'instructions génétique lui permettant
de continuer à vivre sans se détraquer
[Musique]
il y a une séquence qui manque
effectivement puisque lorsque nous
arrivons à la maturité se dire autour de
18 20 ans nos mécanismes se dérègle et
effectivement cette partition qui était
parfaitement écrite qui arrivait à des
choses positives qui arrivent à un
adulte en pleine possession de ses
moyens et bien elle se dérègle et il y a
une accumulation d'erreurs qui vont à ce
moment-là être globalement néfastes qui
vont représenter le vieillissement et ce
vieillissement va faire le lit de la
maladie et va nous faire disparaître
avec une période d'handicap plus ou
moins courte plus ou moins longue et
c'est ce que redoute la plupart des gens
la plupart des gens d'ailleurs n'ont pas
peur de la mort ils ont peur de cette
période de handicap qui est avant la
mort
et à partir de là nous comprenons mieux
ce qui est arrivé à Brook
le chef d'orchestre en elle était
déficiente depuis le début
[Musique]
qu'elle a en elle depuis toujours un
mauvais chef d'orchestre
si dès le départ le chef d'orchestre
n'est pas bon les musiciens ne vont pas
parvenir à interpréter correctement le
thème
c'est ce défaut qui affecte les gènes de
régulation de Brooke et qui empêche son
organisme de se développer normalement
mais l'existence d'un mauvais chef
d'orchestre est importante pour la
science parce qu'elle nous conduit à
chercher le bon chef celui qui nous
permettra de vivre sans nous détériorer
au-delà de la maturité
et finalement ce que le cas
extraordinaire de la petite Brooke nous
apprend c'est que demain si nous
parvenons à trouver la bonne séquence
génétique qui commande la suite de la
partition c'est-à-dire notre longévité
alors nous tiendrons enfin la solution
ça veut dire que demain à 15 ans 20 ans
25 ans on va être capable de modifier et
de de corriger nos différents systèmes
de réparation pour faire que cet homme à
partir de 18 20 ans et bien restaure en
permanence ses capacités on se réparera
nous-mêmes et on est capable de le faire
à 18 à 18 ans nos systèmes fonctionnent
ils sont opérationnels ce n'est qu'après
qu'il se dégrade donc si ces systèmes
restent opérationnels et bien
effectivement on n'a plus de raison de
penser que cette espérance de vie qu'on
fixe actuellement de façon statistique à
120 ans en terme d'espérance de vie
maximum et bien on peut penser qu'elle
va pouvoir durer 150 200 et puis
beaucoup plus
[Musique]
bien sûr nul ne sait qu'en se réalisera
ce grand espoir que nous offre la
biologie mais en attendant que faire
bien certainement pas rester les bras
croisés c'est ce qu'on a pensé très tôt
ici dans le monde bigarré de Venice
Beach en Californie
c'est de Vénus dans les années 60 qui
est parti le célèbre mouvement anti-âge
porté par une génération celle des
baby-boomers il s'est construit à la
fois sur la contre-culture les
découvertes de la biologie qui
s'accumulaient et une philosophie de la
vie qui se cherche
ils ont vu leurs parents où ils voient
leurs parents vieillir et mal vieillir
c'est-à-dire essayer de trouver une
maison de retraite être préoccupé par
des problèmes de couches etc c'est pas
ça qui veulent ils en sont maintenant à
la retraite ils veulent en profiter ils
veulent en profiter debout et donc là on
retrouve typiquement l'esprit américain
c'est-à-dire un esprit non pas
d'assistanat mais un esprit de lutte je
veux en être je me bats pour ça et donc
comment vont-ils arriver à faire ça ils
vont travailler sur la rééquilibration
de l'ensemble des déséquilibres qui se
sont installés dans leur organisme
[Musique]
et puisque nous étions avait Nice nous
avons mis le cap sur Palm sprint
[Musique]
niché en plein désert à 170 km de Los
Angeles Palm Springs et réputé pour ses
parcours de golf
mais c'est aussi le lieu de villégiature
des riches retraités californiens et de
quelques stars d'Hollywood
tout naturellement que le docteur Shine
a fondé son institut
décrié par les uns loués par d'autres le
docteur Shine est un pionnier de
mouvement anti-âge
il fut le premier il y a une quinzaine
d'années a proposé à grande échelle une
thérapie reposant sur le rééquilibrage
hormonal
sur son site très alléchant le docteur
Shine dévoile sa formule nous faire
vivre et vieillir comme les mouettes
le processus de vieillissement chez les
humains est différent de celui des
mouettes les hommes vieillissent à cause
de la baisse de leur taux d'hormones
c'est à cause de cela que nous tombons
malades et que nous mourrons
les hormones des mouettes restent toute
leur vie durant leur seuil optimal ce
qui fait qu'elles vivent en pleine forme
sans tomber malade
et quand la fin arrive elle tombe dans
l'océan et elle meurt
le principe de mon traitement est très
simple il s'agit d'imiter les mouettes
c'est à dire de maintenir notre niveau
hormonal à son seuil optimal tout au
long de notre vie
pour mieux comprendre ce qui se passe au
coeur du vivant on peut prendre
l'exemple d'une automobile
regardez le tableau de bord indique les
niveaux des fluides indispensables à la
bonne marche du moteur l'eau l'huile
essence
pour l'homme voici le tableau de bord
les sécrétions hormonales indispensables
à la vie
par exemple les hormones thyroïdiennes
qui contrôlent la production de chaleur
de notre corps la mélatonine qui nous
aide à trouver un sommeil réparateur
l'hormone de croissance qui accroît la
masse et la tonicité de nos muscles la
DHEA sécrétée par nos glandes surrénales
et qui aurait un effet sur la libido la
peau et les os
et tout comme les fluides dans une auto
notre taux d'hormones chute à mesure que
nous vieillissons
voici comment entre 10 et 90 ans décroît
votre taux d'hormones thyroïdienne
et là ce n'est pas mieux pour la DHEA
même chute pour la mélatonine
et bien sûr pareil pour l'hormone de
croissance
on mange les hormones sont comme des
emails des courriels c'est un message
envoyé par nos organes vers l’adn de nos
chromosomes quand notre toux d'hormone
décroît le signal transmis décroît lui
aussi et dans ce cas l'ADN ne capte pas
bien le message
et comme il ne capte pas bien le message
la nouvelle génération de cellules qu'il
reproduit n'est pas saine ce sont des
cellules porteuses de maladies
pour le docteur Shine cette chute des
sécrétions hormonales explique pourquoi
avec l'âge il devient nécessaire de
rétablir les équilibres rompus en
quelque sorte d'amener notre auto au
garage
son site web regorge de 15 exemplaires
du style avant après avant ils avaient
l'âge de leurs hormones et donc ils se
sentait fatigué et vieux très vieux
avant de consulter le docteur Chen il y
a 11 ans maintenant je me sentais
vieillir je ne jouais plus très bien au
tennis mon cerveau semblait fonctionner
au ralenti j'en étais arrivé à un point
où je me sentais toujours fatiguée
j'avais toujours besoin de dormir
le docteur Shine intervient avec ce
qu'il faut bien l'appeler une
merveilleuse astuce trompez notre ADN
grâce au supplément hormonaux contenus
dans ces petites boîtes
Evariste ma méthode consiste à restaurer
votre taux hormonal et le ramener à
celui de vos 20 ans par exemple si vous
avez aujourd'hui 60 ans je ramène votre
tour hormonal au niveau de celui que
vous aviez lorsque vous étiez plus jeune
votre ADN recevra alors un message
hormonal qui lui dira que vous êtes
jeune si bien que les cellules qui
seront reproduites alors seront des
cellules jeunes saines et plus des
cellules de 60 ans
[Musique]
l'heure comme s'ils avaient retrouvé
leur 20 ans
il fait vous avez l'impression d'être
revenu 20 ans en arrière c'est
extraordinaire
vous avez une énergie incroyable vous
avez envie de vous remettre à faire du
sport en fait vous retrouvez ce que vous
étiez auparavant
mon agilité mentale m'a force physique
on changeait depuis que je suis allé à
l'Institut j'ai la sensation qu'ils ont
retrouvé le niveau qui était le leur
quand j'avais 30 ans c'est bien sûr
caricatural comme une publicité
grossière cependant les résultats sont
là des milliers d'hommes et de femmes
dans le monde ont tenté l'expérience du
rééquilibrage hormonal et en proclame
les bienfaits toutefois aussi importante
qu'elle soit les hormones ne sont qu'une
pierre dans un édifice autrement
complexe le docteur Chen est le
représentant tipi de la vision
américaine du tout hormonal donc ça
c'est parfait parce que ça correspond à
une attente de beaucoup de patience
c'est à dire une attente simpliste
on a un problème on a une solution on
fait une injection boom c'est fini tout
repart en réalité la nature et la
physiologie humaine c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça et c'est ce qui fait que
je dirais que peu de gens accèdent à
cette médecine de la longévité c'est
parce que ça implique de changer son
mode de vie ça implique de manger
différemment s'implique de faire du
sport ça implique de prendre des
hormones ou des correcteurs
physiologiques mais ça implique un
ensemble de choses et cette espèce de
réaction qui est une réaction presque de
recherche de solutions magiques comme le
faisait au Moyen-Âge ou même à d'autres
périodes reculées du temps certains rois
ou personne riche ici qui mangeait
simplement des testicules d'animaux ou
de taureau pour retrouver une certaine
jeunesse c'est pas si simple que ça
je vais à présent vous demander de vous
avancer
afin de recevoir votre prix Nobel des
mains de Sa Majesté le Roi
franchissant maintenant une nouvelle
étape au-delà des hormones une autre
piste se dessine depuis une vingtaine
d'années pour les chercheurs celle des
télomères
[Musique]
en 2009 le prix Nobel de médecine a été
attribué à ces trois chercheurs
Elisabeth Blackburn Carole gruder et
Jacques chostap pour leur découverte du
mécanisme de protection des chromosomes
par les
[Musique]
de quoi s'agit-il tout simplement des
extrémités de nos chromosomes
c'est comme la protection en plastique
dans lacets de chaussures
elle empêche le lacet de s'effilocher
hélas chaque fois qu'une de nos cellules
se divisent la longueur de nos télomères
diminue chaque division agit comme un
passage de rabot
et un jour c'est terminé privé de sa
protection le lacet de nos chromosomes
se détériore et nos cellules s'abîment
un peu plus à chaque division c'est la
vieillesse puis la mort
un de l'histoire et bien non la suite se
passe à la cafétéria de l'aéroport de
Seattle
thé dans cet enzyme que voici elle est
produite naturellement par l'organisme
son nom la télomérase
devant l'écran rencontrer entre deux
avions le biologiste Michael fossel un
des chercheurs qui travaillent
aujourd'hui sur l'enzyme miracle
la télomérase contrôle la manière dont
vos cellules se réparent d'une
génération à l'autre
nous pourrions l'utiliser pour recaler
le processus du vieillissement dans les
cellules
normalement la télomérase ne s'exprime
que dans les cellules sexuelles et les
cellules cancéreuses
en protégeant leur télomères et leur
donne la capacité de se reproduire
indéfiniment
mais à présent imaginez imaginez qu'on
installe dans votre corps pour chaque
cellule un interrupteur capable
d'activer ou au contraire d'inhiber la
production de télomérase
la télomérase joue un rôle très
important dans les cellules cancéreuses
et dans le vieillissement il faut
l'activer pour stopper le vieillissement
et les maladies majeures et il faut le
désactiver dans les cellules cancéreuses
pour empêcher leur prolifération mais il
ne suffit pas d'allumer ou d'éteindre
l'interrupteur nous voulons contrôler le
mécanisme pour soigner tout ce qui doit
l'être
[Musique]
l'idée est bien sûr géniale mais comment
la réaliser il existe de nombreux pistes
mais les chercheurs aujourd'hui mettent
leur espoir dans cette petite planche
c'est une plante connue de la médecine
chinoise depuis 2000 ans et il se trouve
qu'un facteur de cette plante active la
télomérase ce que nous voudrions faire
c'est l'utiliser sur des patients et
voir l'effet produit sur leur
vieillissement
ce qu'on peut en attendre selon moi ce
n'est pas seulement une fille plus
longue mais une vie en bien meilleure
santé pour l'allongement de la vie ce
n'est pas à 10 ans 20 ans de plus mais
probablement 100 ou 200 ans mais encore
une fois personne ne veut vivre plus
longtemps dans un hôpital nous voulons
aussi vivre mieux jouer au tennis
profiter de nos arrières arrières
petits-enfants à garder la santé 20 30
40 ans de plus je crois vraiment qu'on
aboutira dans une dizaine d'années
[Musique]
plus loin dans l'avenir une nouvelle
frontière a vaincre la très grande
longévité plusieurs siècles de vie
à Denver dans le Colorado nous avons
rencontré le docteur Terry Grossman
dans son dernier livre à succès il ose
poser cette question serons-nous
immortels
ces méthodes la prévention et les hautes
technologies il a déjà pris les devants
au cas où demain il aurait une attaque
cardiaque
si demain j'avais une attaque cardiaque
je préférerais tout de même que les
lieux dans un endroit où les médecins
savent se servir des cellules souches
j'ai pris soin d'en conserver quelques
unes il y a quelques années qui me
serait très utile
faute de cela les médecins doivent
d'abord prélever des cellules souches
dans le ventre du patient
puis il les injecte directement dans son
cœur ce qui permet d'arrêter les dégâts
tout cela c'est donc pour le très proche
à venir mais demain et après deux
révolutions attendent la médecine la
première c'est celle de la nanomédecine
[Musique]
est une médecine pratiquée à l'échelle
d'un anneau maître un nanomètre étant la
taille approximatif d'un atome il s'agit
donc d'une médecine à l'échelle de
l'atome aujourd'hui les chercheurs ont
mis au point des sphères microscopiques
qu'il remplissent de médicaments
il est injecte dans le sang et il les
conduisent à leur destination pour
éliminer les cellules cancéreuses
c'est ce type de médecine qui sera
accessible à tous dans les 10 prochaines
années
[Musique]
la seconde révolution la plus décisive
sera celle des nano robots et cette fois
la très grande longévité est en vue mais
alors les nano robots sont de très
petits instruments qui seront construits
dans l'avenir nous n'avons pas encore
les technologies pour cela ces robots
seront injectés dans le corps où ils
circuleront dans le flux sanguin pour
réparer des dégâts ciblés ce sont les
petits sous-marins du futur que nous
verrons apparaître aux alentours de 2030
entre 2030 et 2040 ce qui nous permettra
de compter notre âge en siècle plutôt
qu'on définit
[Musique]
mais attention il ne s'agit plus la
seulement de médecine ou de technologie
car à l'air des nanorobos se sont les
fondements même de nos sociétés qui
seront bouleversées
je crois que l'aspect technique n'est
pas l'aspect qui nous posera le plus de
problèmes le plus difficile sera de nous
adapter aux conséquences de ces
technologies car c'est toute notre vie
qui sera bouleversée
[Musique]
vous voyez ce qui se passe avec le débat
sur les retraites on discute de quelques
années mais imaginez que demain on
discute d'une extension de la vie de 50
ans de 100 ans qu'est-ce qui va se
passer
qui va pouvoir en bénéficier
parce que ça aussi c'est un problème
parce que tant qu'il y a une centaine de
personnes ça va si on a 10000 qu'est-ce
que ça représente qu'est-ce que ça va
signifier pour ceux qui ne vont pas en
bénéficier ou qui ne voudront pas en
bénéficier et puis imaginez enfin le
choc Nord-Sud parce que il est pas
possible de penser que nous en tant que
occidentaux nous bénéficions d'une vie
qui peut monter à 150 200 ans en bonne
santé d'accord pas grabataire dans un
miroir mais actif vous l’en travaillez
vous l'encrer
et d'un autre côté par exemple un
continent africain ou dans certaines
régions vous avez 50% d'une population
qui a moins de 15 ans qu'est-ce qui va
se passer
[Musique]
poursuivons notre tour du monde nous
arrivons à Ben ares en Inde la ville
sacrée au bord du gang
Bénarès la ville des morts et nous voici
au cœur des croyances et des mythes ces
hommes et ces femmes sont habités par
une conviction en venant mourir à
bénavès il se donneront une chance de
rompre le cycle des réincarnations et
d'accéder ainsi au nirvana
[Musique]
au soir venu le mort couvert de fleurs
est amené jusqu'au Ganges où il est
purifié
puis il est placé sur un bûcher le feu
est apporté depuis le temple de Shiva
par l'homme le plus âgé de la famille
personne ne pleure
réuss réussir sa vie c'est réussir sa
mort mieux que cela c'est quitter enfin
le cycle de la vie pour exister sur un
autre plan celui de la béatitude
pour nous les funérailles sont un
système de redistribution
l'énergie revient à sa forme originelle
pour reformer un nouveau corps
[Musique]
est la plus petite partie de l'absolu et
quelle languette elle fusionne avec
l'absolument on ne peut pas la détruire
on ne peut pas la réduire ensemble elle
demeure
très occidentale de prolonger la vie et
bien difficile à comprendre c'est
pourquoi à la veille de la grande
révolution de la longévité sans doute
nous faut-il atteindre une nouvelle
conception de la vie pour être vraiment
capable de vivre pleinement 150 ans 200
ans peut-être beaucoup plus
[Musique]
ainsi pour Jean-Claude la maïzen
biologiste membre du comité d'éthique
l'allongement de la vie ne deviendra un
progrès que s'il nous conduit à
revisiter l'ensemble de nos valeurs on
parle beaucoup de développement durable
et la question c'est voulons-nous faire
durer pour une partie de l'humanité les
tragédies actuelles où voulons nous
faire en sorte que le développement soit
équitable que l'humanité vive dans une
situation équitable et à ce moment de le
faire durer donc je crois que pour
l'allongement de l'espérance de vie
qu'on espère c'est la même chose
essayons de faire en sorte d'être le
plus humain possible avec chaque
personne avec chaque enfant qui
aujourd'hui habite sur terre et si nous
y réussissons et bien essayons de faire
en sorte que cette bonne vie soit le
plus long possible
pour finir voici Brooke encore et une
dernière fois son handicap nous
aidera-t-il la levée à un coin du voile
à progresser dans la compréhension des
secrets les mieux cachés de la vie et de
l'évolution
peut-être mais comment ne pas être saisi
d'émotions devant ces grands yeux perdus
dans le van il reflète le malheur mais
aussi pour l'humanité entière un immense
espoir
[Musique]
au terme de cette étonnant rendez-vous
avec l'allongement de la vie peut-être
ressentez-vous pour la première fois que
nous sommes au bord d'une fantastique
révolution sans doute la plus importante
pour l'humanité oui Grichka hier vieux à
80 ans demain jeûne à 120 télé entre
autres le slogan de tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui vont conquérir la très
grande longévité un immense défi mais
pour le relevé pour entrer dans ce monde
nouveau qui est là juste devant nous il
faudra accepter cette idée que la
vieillesse finalement n'est pas un
phénomène naturel mais bien une
véritable maladie une maladie que nous
aurons un jour les moyens de guérir une
fois pour toutes alors préparez-vous à
vivre cette longue et belle jeunesse 20
ans pendant trois siècles et n'oubliez
jamais que dans l'univers rien même ce
qui aujourd'hui vous paraît incroyable
rien n'est impossible
[Musique]
bienvenue à tous dans quelques instants
vous avez rendez-vous avec l'un des
mystères les plus controversés dans
notre temps une question qui soulève
d'innombrables débats parfois enflammés
et ceux depuis plus d'un demi siècle
sans qu'à ce jour aucune conclusion
définitive n'est encore plus être
apportée il s'agit de ce phénomène
énigmatique connu sous le nom d'objets
volants non identifié les ovnis mais de
quoi s'agit-il d'un incroyable complot
des liaisons d'optique de croyances
collectives ou encore d'autres choses ce
phénomène multiforme semble échapper à
toute tentative de classification
scientifique pourquoi essentiellement
parce que les observations de ces
mystérieuses objets aperçus dans le ciel
parfois à terre sont toujours uniques un
certain fugace sujette à caution en bref
on ne peut pas les reproduire pour les
étudier scientifiquement
et pourtant les témoignages s'accumulent
par dizaines de milliers alors pour
tenter d'y voir un peu plus clair nous
avons donc proposé à une institution
scientifique le Centre national d'études
spatiales le CNES d'ouvrir pour nous les
nombres dossiers dont ils disposent et
qui ont été étudiés archivés depuis des
années et pour la première fois à la
télévision avec les chercheurs du CNES
nous allons donc réfléchir ensemble à
cette énigme tenace pourquoi après plus
de 60 ans les ovnis demeurent-ils
toujours aussi mystérieux est-il
seulement possible d'apporter une
réponse à cette question pour commencer
nous proposons de revenir sur un
événement qui a eu un très grand
retentissement la mise en ligne par le
CNES des archives du GEPAN le service
chargé d'enquêter depuis plus de 30 ans
sur les ovnis service que le CNES a
rebaptisé pan phénomène aérospatio non
identifié c'était le 22 mars 2007
première étape de notre enquête la Cité
de l'espace à Toulouse
c'est là qu'a été réalisé une exposition
complète sur le phénomène OVNI et nous y
avons trouvé une foule de choses un
intérieur de vaisseau spatial des
extraterrestres à profusion et même
cette reconstitution d'un bureau
d'enquête sur les ovnis inspiré par le
génie pan de l'agence spatiale française
membre du CNES a participé à la mise en
ligne des fameuses archives une journée
historique alors nous l'attendions cette
journée du 22 mars parce qu'on avait
déjà des avants des avant-bruits des
signes avant-coureurs que ça risquait de
provoquer un grand intérêt donc à 10h
conférence de presse sont présentes le
site Mon tout va bien le site est ouvert
au public et puis la conférence de Brest
termine vers 11h 11h30 quelque chose
comme ça une heure après catastrophe le
site du gipan avait sauté à cause trop
de connexion et le site du CNES avait
lui-même sauté
les internautes ils cherchaient à savoir
ce qu'il y avait là-dedans c'est pas le
vieillitant mais c'est un faxilé
qu'est-ce que vous cachez depuis 30 ans
en fait on ne cache rien simplement on
ne communiquait pas donc désormais
allez-y c'est ouvert vous allez regarder
alors que trouve-t-on dans ces archives
des milliers de témoignages et
maintenant de toutes les régions de
France
parmi eux les plus troublants sont ceux
des pilotes leur formation leur a donné
une bonne connaissance des phénomènes
qu'on observe dans le ciel et donc une
bonne aptitude à distinguer le vrai du
faux
voici Jacques crime ancien pilote de
chasse sur Mirage 3
son observation une des plus célèbres
au-dessus du territoire national date de
1973 nous étions en mission
d'interception de nuit à bord de mirage
3 qui était bon les avions assez pointus
de l'époque avec surtout équipé d'un
radar de tir qui lui permettait de faire
des rassemblements de nuit nous
entraîner à cet exercice et au moment en
fin de rassemblement nous les étions
guidés par un radar au sol apparaît dans
le trajectoire quelque chose qui
ressemblait à priori à l'avion de ligne
c'est-à-dire affusage assez longue avec
des hublots et des lumières intérieures
donc j'appelle le contrôle au sol
j'écoute là c'est pas bon on va voir
sur le radar confirmé alors je demande
aussi à mon équipier qui me confirme ce
que je voyais effectivement il confirme
que moi qu'on voyait passer à disons un
objet en vol qui était dans le
trajectoire et qui ressemblait à priori
à la journée et effectivement dernière
vision que j'ai ça ressemblait un peu la
forme d'un ballon de rugby peinture
assez grand et très très éclairé de
l'intérieur je vous rappelle il y avait
une lumière très très blanches qui
n'ébolissait pas mais très éclairée et
au moment où on se rapproche à une
distance que peut-être
c'était l'histoire de sécurité pour lui
disparaît dans l'espace avec une vitesse
traduisant les microsecondes de rien
et disparaît sur une trajectoire de deux
ou trois degrés sur dans notre horizon
et nous laisse sur place je le rappelle
l'image que j'ai eu c'était les Dupont
qui était dans le désert sur le Jeep qui
sont doublés par une voiture il y en a
qui descend on dit pourquoi on est
arrêté enfin c'était la passion qu'on
avait déjà posé sur place dans l'idéal
les pilotes sont censés rapporter leurs
observations à leur hiérarchie dont le
rôle et de les transmettre ensuite au GP
pourtant les choses ne se passent pas
toujours ainsi il y a un problème
d'auto-censure oui de parce que les
pilotes de par leur métier sont soumis
d'une surveillance médicale et
psychologique relativement serré et
forte et
beaucoup de beaucoup de pilotes
effectivement évitent d'en parler ou
alors n'en parle que quand ils sont
quand ils sont à la retraite quand ils
ont quitté le
l'activité
pendant 11 ans Jacqueline a gardé le
silence sur son observation
et il s'en explique aujourd'hui sur le
petit aérodrome de Lognes devant
d'autres pilotes mais pardon mais vous
en avez parlé dans le cadre de votre
famille par exemple à des proches
la timidité ou la pudeur qu'on peut
avoir parce que le regard des autres et
qu'on dira-t-on c'est quand même fort et
ceci c'est les oignons on en parle
depuis longtemps je vais y aller et à
chaque fois que il y a leur action qui
est très forte émotionnellement vous
passez pour un rigolo quoi d'ailleurs
c'est surtout ça c'est la
déconsidération le grand savant qui ont
tous en savoir donc contexte de l'ordre
de leur boulot ils se mettait au bon si
vous voulez parce qu'il y a un mode de
pensée qui est très stricte et ça ça
touche quelque chose qui va au delà je
dirais ou de adieu du rationnel
un autre témoignage très troublant a eu
lieu en 1973 il émane d'un pilote
d'alouette 2 un pilote militaire alors
c'est pour ça sans doute qu'il a voulu
garder l'anonymat heureusement il nous a
confié son récit par écrit et nous
allons ensemble tenter de savoir comment
les choses se sont passées
dans l'hélicoptère un côté d'Igor
Stéphane Caplier il est passionné depuis
longtemps par la question des ovnis et
il va nous lire le témoignage transmis
par le pilote que nous appellerons
pierre
[Musique]
pierre était un jeune pilote de
l'aviation légère de l'armée de terre du
troisième groupe d'hélicoptère léger à
bord dans son Alouette II il effectue un
vol entre reines Saint-Jacques et Caen
tout d'un coup si tourne la tête et il
se rend compte que l'hélicoptère est
doublé par un immense dirigeable non
comme un paquebot je cite 100 hublot
sans lumière sans filmer sans aucune
perturbation instrumentale qui se
déplace donc plus vite que lui à ce
moment-là tout à fait puisque après une
observation de plus d'une seconde
contact à tour de contrôle de Caen et le
contrôleur voit lui-même un déco radar
il confirme oui tout à fait il voit un
décor radar traverser l'écran du nord au
sud et à très grande vitesse alors pour
le pilote c'est un ovni au sens
extraterrestre au niveau des mesures il
voit quelque chose de 200 à 300 mètres
de long quelque chose de griternes une
épaisseur très importante pas de bruit
alors débouche un vif comme un
dirigeable je sais pas ce qu'il entend
par bouche ce sont les nervures à la
surface de la Coop du dirigeable voilà
donc c'était assez pointu à l'avant
comme en arrière et en plus ils disent
qu'ils n'ont pas eu peur sur le coup
mais que par la suite évidemment ils
étaient un peu tendus alors il précise
mais on les croit sur parole qu'il
n'avait pas bu dit grossover drogue
surtout dans l'armée et qui n'avait rien
à voir ni à proposer qui souhaitait
faire aucun effet d'annonce et ça c'est
lui qui le dit tout ça c'est lui tout ça
entre guillemets c'est propos sont
véridiques incroyable il le sait mais
véridique
alors confronté à un phénomène aussi
multiforme aussi mystérieux que le
phénomène OVNI et bien la seule démarche
consiste à évidemment à adopter une
démarche scientifique c'est ce qu'on
fait au gipan à l'intérieur du CNES
depuis plus de 30 ans on a accumulé
quantité de dossiers des analyses des
investigations qu'on a mené sur le
terrain et on a donc classé ces
phénomènes en quatre catégories d'abord
en a on a trouvé des phénomènes
parfaitement et expliqués parfaitement
d'identifier ensuite en B on va
rassembler les phénomènes probablement
identifiés en C on va considérer que le
rapport est incomplet et qu'on ne peut
donc pas se faire une opinion et enfin
en D on va rassembler les phénomènes
réellement inexpliqués nous avons ça
tout de suite quelques exemples de
faux-ongles
[Musique]
commençons par une histoire insolite
classée en B c'est à dire les phénomènes
probablement expliqués
cet objet est tombé du ciel le 25
février
1985 et il a creusé un trou de belles
tailles au milieu d'un champ dans la
région de Royan
deux paysans sont témoins du phénomène
l'objet atterri devant devant leurs yeux
dans le champ à une trentaine ou une
cinquantaine de mètres et après
plusieurs robots s'est stabilisés
les deux personnes se rapprochées de cet
objet qui semblait encore très très
chaud et fumant
ce sont décidés la brigade de
gendarmerie locale qui est venu sur les
lieux et ils sont arrivés à peu près une
heure et demie l'objet était froid dans
ils ont pu ils ont pu s'en approcher
[Musique]
le premier aspect visuel je dirais de
l'objet c'était quelque chose qui
ressemblait à de l'oxyde de fer au
granuleux sous la forme d'un cylindre de
50 à 60 cm de long sur 15 cm de diamètre
avec aucune marque extérieure apparente
donc cet objet a été récupéré par la
brigade de gendarmerie il a été
expertisé à la demande des gendarmes par
des laboratoires du coin qui ne
spécialiste en armement qui n'ont
reconnu d'ailleurs cet objet aucun
missile aucune arme connue à l'heure
actuelle
aussitôt les gendarmes alerte le géant
de l'époque service chargé d'enquêter
sur les ovnis
et le résultat ne tarde pas il s'agit
d'un morceau de satellite artificiel
russe qui s'est consumée dans
l'atmosphère
affaire classique donc et pourtant
l'histoire rebondit 3 ans plus tard
quand le geppan qui a récupéré l'objet
en conflit l'expertise à un laboratoire
de la DGA la Direction générale de
l'armement
donc ça a été découpé tout ça bon
l'objet avait certains certains orifices
qui présentaient des les marques de
combustion supposées etc et en ouvrant
tout ça on s'est aperçu faire ce
laboratoire c'est aperçu qu'il y avait
différentes inscriptions là dessus
et donc dans la base à l'intérieur qu'on
ne pouvait pas avoir au départ on s'est
aperçu qu'il y avait quelques numéros
avec un insigne qui a été
identifié comme l'insigne allemande du
Troisième Reich c'est-à-dire l'aigle
avec la croix gammée dessus
alors donc l'interprétation évidemment
qui a été la plus répandue immédiatement
à l'époque bah c'était un morceau de
satellite espion allemand
un satellite nazi dans l'espace il est
vrai que vers la fin de la guerre les
Allemands dans leur base de penémoundé
avait expérimenté de nombreuses armes
nouvelles dont les célèbres V2 mais de
là à envoyer un engin dans l'espace il
n'en était certainement pas capable
c'est alors intervenir le principe de
raison suffisante qui consiste à éviter
d'avoir recours à l'hypothèse ovnie
lorsqu'une explication simple peut
suffire voici donc la solution de
l'énigme
il s'est avéré que cet objet là était un
obus effectivement d'attendre de la fin
de la Seconde Guerre mondiale où les
Allemands qui occupaient Royan c'est la
fameuse histoire de la poche Royan était
coincée dans la poche de Royan par les
Alliés et en s'enfuyant et ben ils ont
mis pas mal de munitions dans les marées
alentours et les marais Poitevins et on
suppose que c'est obus il était resté
pendant toutes ces années
soit dans un marais soit dans un endroit
non accessible par les gens et qui la
combustion ce serait déclenchée soit par
un phénomène de choc ou alors un effet
thermique à long terme
[Applaudissements]
dans cet objet il serait parti de cet
endroit là de se marrer aurait eu une
forme parabolique une trajectoire
parabolique serait tombée au pied dans
le champ des deux paysans voilà après
mouton rebond et donc voilà ben ce qui
était au départ en OVNI et devenu
quelque chose de tout à fait rationnel
et expliquer c'était juste un obus de la
demande de la deuxième guerre mondiale
Ivan blanc nous a montré quelque pages
des conférences à but pédagogiques
qu'ils donnent sur la question des
observations aisément explicables
classées en a nuage lenticulaire foudra
boule rentrer atmosphérique de
météorites ou de satellites artificiels
etc
et voici un nouveau venu en France qui
fait désormais un pourcentage
appréciable des rapports d'OVNI ce sont
les lanternes thaïlandaises
ce sont des petites montgolfières en
papier qui peuvent aller de 40 cm de
hauteur jusqu'à très gros jusqu'à 1 m si
on les confectionne sur mesure dans
lesquelles on a un petit carburant qui
est allumé c'est le principe de la
montgolfière qui ont l'air à l'intérieur
est chaud tout ça s'envole donc ce
phénomène est en train de gagner
l'Europe et en particulier la France on
a de plus en plus d'observations et de
rapport et ces phénomènes sont liés à
des lâcher de l'antenne thaïlandaise
comme on voit ici sur ce film
curieux les gens sont toujours déçus
quand on leur amène une explication un
peu rationnelle de leur de leur
observation je dirais c'est vrai pour
les Lantern thaïlandaises mais c'est
vrai également pour toutes les autres
observations je veux dire
enfin il y a la question immense des
photos et des vidéos il y en a des
milliers comme on peut le constater en
surfant sur Internet
alors comment démêler le vrai du faux
François Hollande expert en images
analyse pour nous quelques photos de
faux OVNI
commençons par ces clichés pris par un
jeune collégien
ils évoquent une véritable escadrille de
soucoupes volantes se trouve que
l'analyse de ces photos permet de
montrer de 5 ou 6 de mémoire façon
différente qu'il s'agit d'un faux d'une
façon très précise ce gamin a collé des
petits objets en forme d'OVNI sur la
fenêtre de sa chambre et à profiter du
flou ambiant pour faire des photos qui
donnaient une impression tout à fait
bonne alors c'était très instructif
quand c'est arrivé puisque justement je
travaillais sur les méthodes d'analyse
des photos on pouvait montrer par
exemple que c'était pas vrai son
histoire parce que les ovnis étaient
censés être beaucoup plus loin qu'un fil
électrique qui passait tout près de sa
chambre or en analysant de très près
l'image on s'aperçoit que le fil est
caché par l'ovni donc c'est un peu
contradictoire on voit des lois
d'illumination qui s'appliquent tout le
long de l'ovni qui sont très semblables
à celle du bord de la fenêtre ce qui est
quand même coïncidence intéressante on
voit aussi une variation de taille
apparente de ces objets d'une photo à
l'autre qui sont en proportion exacte
des variations de la taille apparente
des éléments de la fenêtre ce qui est
quand même un peu bizarre pour un objet
qui est censé être diss20 ou 50 fois
plus loin etc donc c'est des exemples
comme ça avec lesquels on s'aperçoit que
bon ben finalement s'il est un domaine
dans les ovnis où il y a du faux c'est
plutôt celui des photos
l'expertise a aussi montré que cet objet
insolite photographié par hasard lors
d'un lâché de montgolfière n'était en
réalité qu'un ballon d'enfant dérivant à
300 mètres de distance
et c'est tout l'enjeu de l'analyse de
l'image c'est d'essayer avec des
techniques qui prennent en compte le
flou le la netteté des contours de
l'objet le niveau de grille de ces
objets si vous prenez un objet noir et
que vous l'éloignez plus vous l'éloignez
plus il paraîtra clair ça permet de
faire des rapprochements avec d'autres
objets noirs dans le plan etc
alors à côté des observations
explicables classées en A B et C il
existe donc une autre catégorie de
témoignages que le gipan classe en D ce
sont ces observations pour lesquelles on
ne trouve aucune explication certaines
de ces affaires comme celle de
Trans-en-Provence sont demeurées très
célèbres d'autres sont tout aussi
troublantes mais moins connues on voici
une toute récente qui vient de défrayer
la chronique
l'observation dont Yvan blanc va nous
parler maintenant date de 2007 elle sera
sans doute classée en D les phénomènes
inexpliqués
elle s'est déroulée non loin du CNES
dans la banlieue de Toulouse
l'observation s'est passée exactement
ici le témoin arrivé en véhic avec son
véhicule ici et c'est à peu près à cet
auteur vous voyez entre les deux gros
sapins là que premièrement elle a perçu
une guirlande verte puis aussitôt après
c'est aperçu qu'autour de cette
guirlande il y avait un objet entouré de
lumière en forme circulaire de sous
couple à deux étages avec des lumières
aux deux étages et donc elle était
accompagnée de son enfant elle a pris
aussitôt son téléphone elle appelait sa
mère pour lui décrire l'observation
qu'elle voyait pendant ce temps-là son
enfant était assez émotionné et affolé
dans la voiture et il s'est mis un peu à
pleurer donc elle a elle a arrêté de
suite de son coup de fil en disant son
enfant bon ben arrête l'enfant toujours
en pleurs lui disant maman démarre j'ai
peur donc elle a redémarré si vous
voulez la voiture elle a continué
jusqu'au la prochaine intersection là
elle a tourné à gauche et juste après
l'intersection elle a à nouveau regardé
du côté gauche c'est-à-dire du côté où
elle avait vu la première observation et
là à ce moment-là c'est aperçu que le
phénomène avait complètement disparu
dans le témoin par la suite a fait un
dessin de son observation qui est assez
évocateur et assez détaillé des cinq
voici donc qui représentent la première
petite lumière en forme de verre décrite
par le témoin lumière d'Irlande entourée
de d'un objet en forme de soucoupe avec
deux étages le premier ici le second ici
et chaque étage étant entouré de lumière
orange assez diffuse la dimension de cet
objet était de 5 mètres à peu près et
bon avec les repères qu'il y avait au
monde d'observation
deuxième étape une visite à la brigade
de gendarmerie de Saint-Alban qui a
recueilli le témoignage
que les témoins étaient très choqués la
petite fille avait même du mal à décrire
ce qu'elle avait vu parce que sur le
coup elle avait beaucoup pleuré elle
évitait de regarder l'objet à demander à
sa mère à quitter les lieux mais la mère
est restée sur place
une fois qu'elles sont parties nous
sommes rendus sur les lieux tout d'abord
pour regarder s'il y avait des objets
des traces des indices qui pouvaient se
présenter s'il y en avait eu on aurait
fait un gel des lieux pour faire les
prélèvements dans ce cas là il n'y en
avait pas
[Musique]
de voisinage n'a rien donné
aucune personne n'a pu nous défaire la
même phénomène bon par contre ce qu'il y
a dans notre attention c'est que
vraiment les déclarations de la mère de
la fille décrivait le même objet la même
façon de se déplacer les mêmes couleurs
seul la gendarmerie était habilité à
nous permettre d'entrer en contact avec
les deux témoins la mer et la jeune
fille ont accepté de nous recevoir sous
le couvert de l'anonymat elles ont
répété leur témoignage aux détails près
je me suis dit c'est peut-être bon une
expérience fait par les militaires
parce que j'avais jamais vu ça
donc moi je suis resté à observer bon ma
figurer puisqu'elle avait très très peur
j'ai appelé ma mère sur le portable
justement pour lui dire ce que j'avais
au dessus de moi donc tout en continuant
à observer l'engin ma mère bon m'a dit
ne reste pas là va t'en vite bon je
pense quand même un petit peu la
trouille c'est parce que c'était
les témoins qui vivent une telle
expérience quelle qu'elle soit que
l'explication soit triviale ou pas
vivent quelque chose de très fort sur le
plan émotionnel et s'en souviennent en
général des années et des années
trois ans après vous y pensez encore oui
oui les choses comme ça moi j'ai très
très peur
j'ai pleuré
vous y pensez encore
oui quand des fois que quand je lui
parle comme ça parce que bon j'y repense
c'est vrai que pas trop d'entendre
parler parce que elle est encore été
terrorisée pourquoi je sais pas
voilà quoi ça fait ça fait peur parce
que parce qu'on est dans le domaine de
l'inconnu complet l'inconnu l'inconnu
fait peur
on n'a pas la moindre idée de si ça
existe de ce que ça peut ce à quoi ça
peut ressembler qu'elle peut être le
niveau de technologie on a tout vu dans
les films on a vu iti l'approche
gentille de l'extraterrestre mais on a
vu aussi la guerre des mondes on a vu
donc on sait on a aucune idée de ce qui
pourrait se produire si un tel choc se
produisait donc donc ça fait peur ça me
paraît ça me paraît normal
dans la masse des clichés expertisé par
François louange quelques-uns reste des
énigmes celui-ci par exemple pris
au-dessus du Costa Rica en 1971
alors si on regarde cette photo de très
près on s'aperçoit qu'elle a une forme
bizarre qu'on pourrait qualifier d'une
cymbale vue du dessus ou du dessous si
on la regarde de plus près en gros plan
ça donne ça alors évidemment si elle est
au sol elle représente un objet qui est
très gros si elle est en l'air on n'en
sait rien on ne saura jamais des études
ont été faites pour essayer de voir par
rapport à l'environnement qui elle
taille elle aurait donc si elle était au
sol elle sera assez grande plusieurs
dizaines de mètres dans ce cas-là et
également des mesures qui ont été faites
pour regarder l'éclairage qui plaide
plutôt si l'objet est en bas pour un
objet creux que pour un objet convexe et
puis voilà il y a eu beaucoup de
recherches mais aucune trouvaille de
fait dessus je pense qu'on aura jamais
l'explication finale de cette fameuse
image de Costa Rica qui reste un grand
mystère que je l'appelle un opnyste un
objet photographié non identifié on sait
même pas si ça vole puisque c'est vu sur
l'eau
alors dans le chapitre expliqué je vais
vous montrer quelque chose de totalement
inédit que j'ai dans mes cartons depuis
quelques temps qui m'a été fourni par un
professionnel de l'image qui est un ami
qui s'appelle Raphaël OPI et qui a filmé
pendant un certain temps toute la
trajectoire de la pleine lune dans le
ciel de Barcelone et tout d'un coup en
visionnant ce film il s'est aperçu que
pendant une période de deux minutes que
vous allez voir en accéléré ici il y a
un objet qui passe au-dessus de la lune
avec une trajectoire très étonnante
regardez apparaître l'objet ici on voit
bien qu'il a une trajectoire qui est
tout à fait liée à la lune et pas du
tout à la terre ce que vous venez de
voir se passe en 2 minutes donc cet
objet orbitait certainement autour de la
Lune donc avait une taille en tout cas
ça taille apparente les traces qu'il
laisse qui sont colossales si on se
réfère la lune je le repasse une seconde
fois
[Musique]
voilà
alors c'est quelque chose qui reste tout
à fait inexpliqué puisque aucun travail
approfondie n'a été fait j'espère
pouvoir avec le CNES approcher des des
astronomes déjà pour essayer de
reconstituer à l'heure et à la date où
ont lieu cet événement
est-ce qu'il passait un objet connu en
orbite autour de la Lune ou entre la
Terre la Lune et la Terre je ne sais pas
voilà c'est un cas ouvert tout à fait
inédit
dans la mesure où il contient une grande
part de mystère le phénomène ovni
enflamme les passions
puis toujours il oppose radicalement
deux camps d'un côté il y a les
sceptiques tenant d'une approche
rationnelle et de l'autre il y a les
ufologues un petit peu vous reparler du
5 novembre et ces derniers n'ont aucun
doute sur l'origine extraterrestre de
ces mystérieuses objets nous savons que
nous avons d'énormes indices qui nous
laissent penser que l'hypothèse
extraterrestre est la plus séduisante
voilà où nous en sommes maintenant c'est
une intime conviction ce n'est pas une
croyance c'est pas une question de foi
c'est une question de se pencher sur des
dossiers des dossiers solides des
dossiers politiques des dossiers
militaires des dossiers issus de banque
de l'Air Force américaine des services
de renseignement et une fois que vous
avez mis votre nez dans ces dossiers là
vous ne regardez plus ciel la même façon
c'est une histoire où on avance de deux
ports plus d'un pas mais on avance de
nouveau de deux pas si vous faites
l'addition vous avez quand même avancé
un peu
vous savez le phénomène est
appréhensible c'est-à-dire que il nous
échappe il joue avec nous j'ai
l'impression de ça et que il s'adapte il
s'adapte à notre banque de données il
s'adapte à notre psychologie sa date à
notre siècle il y a eu des véritables
démonstrations aériennes il y a un
témoin militaire un officier qui a vu
une escadrille d'OVNI plongée vers le
sol vers la base aérienne en formation
faire une ressource et remontée à 45
degrés à toute vitesse c'est quoi ça
c'est ce que les philosophes avaient une
démonstration c'est une démonstration
regardez-nous voyez ce que nous savons
faire et réfléchissez
une question beaucoup d'observations
notamment aux États-Unis ont été faites
par des militaires est-ce que vous
pensez vous que l'armée nous cache
quelque chose évidemment sans aucun
doute sans aucun mais qu'est-ce qu'elle
fait
on leur apporte des rapports ils en ont
mais
les détails on peut pas les avoir c'est
ces bouches closes il y a pas
d'informations on nous dit même pas on
nous dit même pas un mensonge
pour nous envoyer balader ça n'existe
pas dormi tranquille messieurs damine
spaspé
nous voici à présent dans le splendide
Park Montsouris à Paris nous y avons
rencontré la doyenne des ufologues
français Francine foireet 85 ans avec
son mari René foiré elle fut à l'origine
d'une des premières associations
écologiques françaises le bulletin des
époux feraient était réputé pour la
qualité et le sérieux de ses comptes
rendus
notre intelligence ne sont peut-être pas
structurés pour comprendre ce phénomène
ça je trouve ça très sage il y a quelque
chose aussi que mon mari m'avait dit si
les soucoupes volantes sont bien des
machines spatiales venues d'ailleurs et
piloter ou téléguidé par des
représentants intelligents d'une ou de
plusieurs races extraterrestres
technicien le problème que leur présence
leur évolution pose n'est pas simplement
un problème intellectuel passionnant
réservé à des esprits savants et curieux
c'est un problème qui intéresse qu'elle
en soit consciente ou non toute
l'humanité
et lorsqu'on demande à Francine Fouéré
si un jour l'humanité finira par
posséder la clé du mystère et là cette
réponse énigmatique ah ça c'est encore
une fois je n'en sais rien parce que ça
ne dépend pas de nous ça dépend de
mais à l'opposé des ufologues il y a
donc les sceptiques et en voici un des
plus irréductibles
Eric maillot le plus surprenant c'est
que ce partisan de la cause rationaliste
fut dans sa jeunesse un fervent adepte
de l'origine extraterrestre des ovnis
c'est vrai que je suis passé du stade de
la croyance donc en hypothèse
extraterrestre
en tout cas on a un phénomène exotique
qui serait nommé phénomène ovni
à quelque chose qui est maintenant une
conviction qui est basée sur la
vérification d'un ensemble de cas et de
cas en cas je me suis rendu compte que
les choses tenaient de moins en moins et
donc forcément je suis devenu sceptique
ça fait le belle durée que dans mes
rêves il n'y a plus de la vie ça a pu
éventuellement se produire dans
l'enfance même pas du tout du tout non
par contre dans mes rêves il y a
beaucoup de choses comme les étoiles les
bolides les météores très très belles
choses qui permettent aussi de rêver
je dirais que je renverrai les gens
d'oado parce que dire que on a un
problème de perception pour tous les cas
qui sont inexpliqués
c'est exactement la même chose de dire
que on a des extraterrestres de tous les
cas qui sont inexpliqués puisque de
l'explication et aussi simple je dirais
d'un côté de l'autre j'ai pas on est
toujours au milieu on marche sur un
chemin assez étroit je dirais bon on est
on a le privilège de d'avoir une
certaine méthodologie lors de nos
enquêtes derrière lesquels on s'appuie
et donc on s'abrit derrière cette
méthodologie pour notre travail de tous
les jours en essayant de pas tenir
compte justement des extrêmes que l'on a
d'un côté ou de l'autre même si comme
vous dites ces extrêmes là sont
énormément présents mais en tant que
représentant légal je dirais de de ces
phénomènes là en France on se doit de
rester neutre ce que l'on essaie de
faire
alors admettons par hypothèse que les
ovnis viennent bien d'un autre monde
comment dans ce cas aurait-il traversé
les gouvres immenses de l'espace vous
savez l'univers est gigantesque pendant
longtemps cette question de distance
rendait les astrophysiciens très
dubitatif au sujet des OVNIS il y a sans
doute de la vie ailleurs disait-il et
peut-être même de la vie intelligente
mais comment imaginer que des visiteurs
viennent de si loin est-ce seulement
possible
face au redoutable problème des
distances les physiciens aujourd'hui
commencent à proposer sérieusement
certaines hypothèses
Pascal Bultel évoque deux moyens
susceptibles un jour de transporter
peut-être les hommes vers les étoiles la
physionucléaire espère-t-on devrait
pouvoir nous permettre d'atteindre des
vitesses de l'ordre de 10% de la vitesse
de la lumière au maximum à ce niveau de
performance 30 000 km par seconde on
estime que l'on pourrait atteindre le
premier groupe d'étoiles le groupe
d'Alpha du Centaure composé du 3 étoiles
en environ 40 ans
voici d'abord le vaisseau tel qu'on peut
l'imaginer
il est immense puisqu'il devra abriter
plusieurs milliers de colons
il voyage aurait trois phases tout
d'abord une phase d'accélération qui
durerait environ deux ans et qui aurait
pour objectif d'emmener le véhicule et
ses passagers à 30000 km/s cette
première phase serait suivie d'une autre
beaucoup plus longue de l'ordre de 35
ans pendant laquelle la propulsion
serait arrêtée enfin la toute dernière
phase de freinage durer environ un an
[Musique]
à noter que le voyage n'aura duré que
quelques dizaines d'années
et la majorité de ceux qui auront
embarqué atteindront l'objectif
[Musique]
et au passage il bénéficieront même d'un
petit bonus prédit par la célèbre
théorie de la relativité d'Einstein
ce que l'on peut dire c'est que les
passagers bénéficient d'un léger effet
positif car c'est en déplacé à une
vitesse qui commence à s'approcher de la
vitesse de la lumière si pour un terrien
le voyage semble avoir duré 40 ans il
aura en fait duré 39 années et quelques
mois pour ses passagers
la deuxième méthode repose sur
l'annihilation matière antimatière
l'antimatière c'est cette matière
inversée dans laquelle les protons sont
négatifs et les électrons positifs
comme il est impossible d'en trouver
dans la nature on doit la fabriquer
nanogramme après nanogramme dans des
accélérateurs de particules
pour la conserver les ingénieurs doivent
impérativement la confiner dans des
champs magnétiques TRÈS intenses
car lorsque l'antimatière rencontre la
matière ordinaire l'énergie libérée est
gigantesque
la production de l'antimatière ne serait
pas réalisée sur terre mais elle serait
le plus probablement réalisé par une
station autour du soleil qui est une
source d'énergie idéale pour produire ce
type de carburant idéal parce qu'il y a
source d'énergie et parce qu'il y a la
distance vis-à-vis de la terre 7
antimatière serait produit par petit
paquet qui serait transféré dans la
partie éloignée de notre système solaire
là où l'on préparerait très concrètement
la mission
[Musique]
avec 30 nanogrammes d'antimatière
environ on pourrait effectuer le voyage
aller-retour Terre Mars avec un dixième
de gramme jusqu'à 1 g d'antimatière on
pourrait atteindre les limites du
système solaire
mais nous visons les étoiles par exemple
celle-ci le système de glise à 20
années-lumière de la Terre découvert
voici quelques années certaines planètes
de ce système pourrait permettre un
atterrissage
[Musique]
voici à présent l'hypothétique vaisseau
spatiale tel qu'on peut l'imaginer
le précieux carburant d'antimatière est
généré en permanence dans ces immenses
anneaux
le vaisseau antimatière pourrait alors
prendre la direction des étoiles
une nouvelle fois le voyage se ferait en
40 ans mais pour aller 5 fois plus loin
qu'avec le vaisseau thermonucléaire de
tout à l'heure et puisqu'on va 5 fois
plus vite les effets relativistes sont
bien plus importants dans ce cas-là un
voyage qui durerait 40 ans vu d'un
terrien ne durerait en fin de compte que
35 ans pour l'équipage
alors cachons de progresser la science
peut nous aider à comprendre les
questions qui se posent à propos des
distances mais il y a des mystères un
petit peu plus troublants et qui
résistent à l'investigation regardez
l'engin vous voyez ici semble immobile
vous l'avez vu tout à l'heure soudain il
disparaît à grande vitesse et c'est
toute la question ces phénomènes
paraissent
et puis il semble en quelque sorte nous
fuir pourquoi le phénomène ovni
reste-t-il donc si difficile à
appréhender
pour tenter de comprendre pourquoi ces
créatures hypothétiques si elles
existent semblent refuser le contact
avec nous
l'astronome Jean-Claude RIB propose une
idée originale
jouant les profilers comme dans les
romans policiers et mettons-nous à leur
place pour comprendre leur motivation de
l'intérieur
repartons vers le futur
rappelez-vous grâce à leur vaisseaux
spatial à propulsion thermonucléaire nos
descendants lointains étaient arrivés
dans la banlieue d'Alpha du Centaure
[Musique]
imaginons maintenant qu'il parviennent à
proximité d'une planète habitable et
habitée
depuis l'espace en restant discret il
découvre une civilisation moins avancée
dont le niveau de technologie est celui
de l'humanité du XXe siècle
on brûle encore du pétrole pour rouler
on s'entasse dans des grandes villes on
se lance dans des guerres meurtrières
pour un oui ou pour un nom alors que
vont faire nos descendants
alors la réponse est quand même assez
vite venue de dire bon on voit ce qui
s'est passé sur terre lorsqu'on a
découvert des pays nouveaux lorsqu'il y
a eu un choc entre deux cultures sans
même parler de vraiment de guerre de
conquête mais la simple mise en présence
d'une culture qui est techniquement
avancée de parfois un siècle ou deux par
rapport à une autre ça peut être un
chemin destructeur donc on va
s'installer par exemple dans on peut
supposer qu'un système solaire un
système scanner autre que notre aura
l'équivalent d'une ceinture d'astéroïdes
comme on a nous et puis de là là on peut
tout à fait imaginer envoyer des des
soucoupes volantes entre guillemets qui
aillent sur une planète qui a une
exploré discrètement
mais peut-être pas trop discrètement
parce que ça pourrait être intéressant
de se dire bon on se laisse un petit peu
voir c'est à dire que les gens petit à
petit comprennent qui sont pas seuls qui
auraient peut-être bien quelqu'un mais
en même temps c'est pas une présence
pesante on leur impose pas notre
existence pour éviter ce fameux choc
technologique et psychologique on peut
dire aussi il faut pas trop les
traumatisé mais cette pas mauvais de
laisser entendre qu'on peut qu'il existe
quelque chose comme vous
dans cette hypothèse on l'a compris nos
descendants seraient les ovnis d'une
civilisation moins avancée il faudrait
donc les habituer progressivement aux
grands compta
selon Jean-Claude dribble c'est
peut-être ce que font avec nous les
ovnis en attendant le bon moment est-ce
que ce bon moment est prêt d'arriver
pourquoi pas c'est ça qu'elle
fantastique à notre époque on dit
souvent nous vivons une époque
fantastique il y a des menaces certes
mais il y a quand même des deux grands
espoirs et c'est intellectuellement
c'est quand même une perspective
fascinante de se dire que peut-être de
notre vivant dans les années où les
décennies qui viennent on va peut-être
avoir ce fameux contact qui redouté par
les uns espérée par les autres mais qui
en tout cas serait un moment formidable
[Musique]
rencontrer dans les magnifiques coupales
du parc de Jolimont à Toulouse Emmanuel
Davout un autre astronome pousse la
spéculation encore plus loin
si les autres existent tout au fond de
l'espace il pourrait avoir 5 bonnes
raisons de refuser le contact
la première c'est celle que je préfère
en fait c'est que les civilisations
extraterrestres sont tournées vers un
monde intérieur vers un monde
contemplatif et que
regarder le ciel et les étoiles ça les
intéresse pas
il y en a d'autres comme celles par
exemple de la de du contraste probable
qu'il y aurait entre nous et une
civilisation beaucoup plus avancée qui
ferait que nous il y aurait une
difficulté de communication parce que on
n'a pas les mêmes valeurs pas les mêmes
connaissances et on aurait sans doute
pas grand chose à se dire donc notre
civilisation n'intéresserait pas les
civilisations plus avancées
[Musique]
on peut aussi prendre l'exemple des des
civilisations dites primitives dans la
jungle qui communiquent par tam-tam
alors que passe par-dessus leur tête
toutes les ondes électromagnétiques de
nos téléphones portables et de nos
émissions de radio et de télévision dont
ils ont absolument pas conscience et qui
ne peuvent pas capter parce que ils
n'ont pas la technologie qu'il faut
ensuite il y a une autre possibilité qui
est peut-être pas très flatteuse pour
nous c'est celle du zoo où nous serions
simplement laissé tranquille dans notre
dans notre réserve naturelle et que il
nous observent à distance
se garde en bien de se montrer de peur
de de nous traumatiser
et enfin il y a aussi celle de la
méfiance parce que finalement nous
sommes ici visiation un petit peu
bruyante qui qui aimait des ondes radio
un petit peu à temps et à travers qui a
envoyé des bombes atomiques dans
l'atmosphère qui
est en train de changer son
environnement peut-être pas à son
avantage et donc peut-être que nous
inspirons la méfiance et qui vaudrait
mieux
se garder de communiquer avec nous
alors à présent vous devez sans doute
vous poser une nouvelle question si ces
êtres
issus d'une biologie non terrestre
existe à quoi pourrait-il donc
ressembler sont-ils différents de nous
ou au contraire est-ce qu'il nous
ressemble
c'est l'occasion peut-être de retourner
à l'exposition de la Cité de l'espace à
Toulouse préparez-vous à la rencontre
disent les affiches mais rencontre avec
qui
monstrueux ou au contraire angélique
dans notre imaginaire l’extraterrestre
prend le plus souvent le visage des
intentions bonnes mauvaises qu'il
nourrit à notre égard comme notre
imaginaire est appelée quand il imagine
un extraterrestre il le classe soit chez
les touts ou les tous mauvais c'est
l'ange ou c'est le démon et on est
bloqué avec ça alors est-ce qu'il faut
se contenter de ça non évidemment parce
que si on se contentait ça on n'irait
pas le chercher on attendrait qu'ils
viennent si c'est un bon ou craindrait
qui viennent système mauvais ce qu'il
faut c'est continuer à faire ce que
l'humanité de fait depuis des
millénaires c'est d'explorer d'aller
vers l'inconnu qu'on imagine un peu mais
pas trop pour se laisser étonnant et
c'est ça qui est à l'origine presque
philosophique de l'entreprise spatiale
c'est ce qu'on a répété il y a 50 ans
dans le droit spatial en disant explorer
c'est l'héritage de l'humanité c'est pas
seulement des planètes c'est pas
seulement des domaines c'est aussi c'est
une mission d'aller vers l'inconnu et à
ce moment là l'inconnu c'est par
définition quelque chose d'ouvert
sera-t-il bon sera-t-il mauvais si au
fond pas la question que j'aime me poser
il sera ce que je vais le rencontrer et
l'histoire que je vais pouvoir
éventuellement avoir en commun avec
l'inconnu vers lequel j'ai et l'histoire
commune qu'on a déjà et bien c'est
d'appartenir à ce même univers d'être
tous moi humains et lui extraterrestre
des enfants des étoiles
et oui tel est le formidable défi qui
dans un avenir encore insondable fera de
l'homme devenu stellaire un habitant
parmi d'autres de l'immense univers
[Musique]
et bien notre rendez-vous s'achève et
pourtant nous n'avons pas dissipé tous
les mystères qui entourent ce phénomène
reste une dernière question le 5
septembre 1977 la sonde américaine
voyageur 1 était lancé vers l'infini
elle se trouve aujourd'hui perdu aux
limites extrêmes de notre système
solaire à plus de 15 milliards de
kilomètres de la Terre et un emporte
dans ses flancs une plaque une plaque
gravée à l'image de l'homme ainsi que de
précieux informations destinées à être
recueillis peut-être un jour très
lointain dans des milliers ou des
millions d'années qui sait par des
intelligences étrangères quelque part
dans les étoiles évidemment nous ne
savons pas si ces êtres existent et
pourtant nous allons alors rencontre et
nous leur envoyons même des messages
alors se pourrait-il que ces
intelligences hypothétiques fassent la
même chose quelle tente de nous faire
comprendre quelles sont là nous n'en
savons rien mais d'ores et déjà à propos
de ces fameuses ovnis une chose est
certaine qu'il s'agisse un grand mythe
moderne ou au contraire d'un fait
objectif non encore élucidé en tout cas
ce phénomène aura eu l'occasion depuis
plus d'un demi-siècle de nous obliger à
nous poser une série de questions
fondamentales sur l'origine de la vie
sur les mystères de l'univers sur les
dimensions de l'espace et sur celle du
temps en tout cas amis tout réalité
qu'ils existent ou pas les ovnis ont au
moins se mérites c'est de nous avoir
habitué à comprendre que dans l'univers
rien n'est impossible
[Musique]